Hey,
this is my new radio plus I'm doing a late night shift mean as a,
as a stick with you as you've added down the road.
Did you destination,
we're going to keep it tucked in here on the,
on the jre when numbers us,
what episodes is,
what is it?
Number five 47 Jody roses here ladies and gentlemen.
This episode is brought to you by stamps.com that's my real voice.
stamps.com is a way that you can run a business since shit from your home or
from your office.
Just using your home computer.
You don't have to go to the post office,
get things weighed out anymore.
You can print official us postage directly from your home computer.
It is a marvel of convenience,
ladies and gentlemen and is what Brian Red band uses the ship everything out.
If you order a tee shirt or hat or any of this cool new things.
If you go to shop squad.tv as a bunch of new shit and all that stuff is handled
by stamps.com our friends Bert Kreischer,
he sends his shit through stamps.com Tom Cigar and Christina present ski.
They send their merchandise through stamps.com stamps.com is an awesome way to
get 24 hour access to the post office,
right from your computer.
No waiting in line,
no hassles printed up on your home computer right there on your printer and then
boom,
give that shit to the mailman and you're done.
Kid stamps.com makes mailing and shipping very easy with any computer,
any printer,
very simple to do Hannity,
a mail carrier and your dignity,
dignity done.
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale automatically that that automatically
calculates the exact postage you need for any class of male.
You'll never need to go to the post office again.
Go right now to stamps.com and use the Promo Code j r e for this special offer.
It's a no risk trial,
$110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
So do not wait.
Go to stamps.com and before you do anything else,
go and click on that microphone in the upper right hand corner.
Who's doing that thing with their mouth?
So you Joda Rosso.
Was it?
Was I doing that?
Doing some weird shit,
man.
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
No worries.
Sorry.
stamps.com use the code word j,
r e and again,
get your hundred $10 bonus offer.
Can't,
can't recommend stamps.com enough.
Literally have never heard one bad thing about them.
They're fucking fantastic.
Use the codeword jre and save yourself some money.
We're also brought to you by blue apron.
Blue Apron is a a fantastic new product or service,
I should say,
that sends you all the ingredients and the recipes with photographs,
detailed photographs,
step by step instructions for you to create your own meals.
Excellent.
Healthy,
five to 700 calories per serving.
But if you eat it,
you would think it would be a lot more than that because it's really good stuff.
Um,
they have a whole bunch of really groovy recipes for all sorts of different
things and they send you new stuff every week.
Like this week I've got chicken breasts,
Gumbo with chicken sausage and Okra pan seared scallops with sauteed Sungolds.
I don't even know when the sun gold is,
but it sounds often awesome.
I don't know what this is either.
Purslane P,
U R s lay n s l a,
n e purslane over Pharaoh.
Farrow's a type of pasta,
right?
A beef Patty Melt Mexican style Turkey Burger cod with pickled grapes in summers
suck.
Attach.
This is awesome stuff and easy to do.
I mean,
I cook a lot,
but um,
you know,
I don't really follow recipes.
I mostly cooked meat like a fucking cave man,
but I've been using blue apron and uh,
even making like complex things,
it's not difficult and made these awesome a ground beef,
stuffed peppers.
They were fantastic.
It was really good and it's fun.
It's exciting to do.
It excites me.
That's right.
I said,
Blue Apron excites me,
and here's how it works.
For nine 99 a meal,
they'll send you the right ingredients in the exact right proportions with
simple recipe recipe instructions right to your door.
Blue Apron includes step by step instructions with pictures,
so it's idiot proof.
It's super easy to do.
They work around your schedule and your dietary preferences to cook.
Cooking takes about a half an hour and shipping is always free.
They never send you the same meal twice.
Short Rib Burgers on Pretzel Buns,
Kung Pao,
chicken tacos.
Yummy Shit,
folks,
you'll cook incredible meals and be blown away by the quality and the freshness.
I have zero complaints there.
Been excellent so far.
Blue apron.com forward slash,
Rogen.
Go there and get your first two meals for free.
That's blue apron.com forward slash,
Rogen.
And then last but not least,
what did we have last but not least,
dollar shave first.
Oh,
that's right.
Sweet bitches.
Dollar Shave Club is back.
If you are a member of Dollar Shave Club,
you know what the fuck is up?
You got to remember to buy razors.
Folks,
that Shit's annoying.
The last thing you want to do is we'd go into your,
the cabinet where you keep all your pills,
your medicine kept looking for a razor.
It doesn't exist.
Like you mother fucker.
I forgot to buy razors.
And especially if you have one of those dickhead bosses,
Brian Read Ben.
What's with all the stubble?
You present an unprofessional appearance.
You have to use her girls.
Raise her with all her hair in it and,
and cold water.
You don't,
you don't want to go to the store for anything more.
The more shit you can get delivered to you,
the battery life will be.
Trust me,
I'm a fucking firm believer and getting shit done online.
Um,
you know,
you gotta find that lock,
plastic fortress.
When you go to the fucking pharmacy where they keep all the,
all the,
all the way locked.
Said,
I want you to cutting your throat right there in front of him.
I can't take fucking buying razors anymore.
There's only one guy with the key has always taken a shit,
you know,
find them.
Uh,
with this,
with,
with dollar Shave club.com dollar shave club.com you can for a few bucks a
month,
cut all that shit out of your life.
It's a much smarter way than going into the store.
Their plans start at just $3 a month.
Signing up takes just two minutes,
then sit back and blades arrive like clockwork.
The razors are better than the big shave companies for a fraction of the price.
You can shave with a fresh blade every week,
no membership fees,
no commitments,
and they have a money back guarantee.
You have nothing to lose by trying them out.
So stop fucking around and go to dollar shave club.com/rogan that's dollar shave
club.com/rogan and last but not least,
we're brought to you by on at.com.
It's o,
n,
I.
T.
We have new cups that came in to conquer cups.
They're inspirational cups.
This one a is the meal Motu Musashi Cup.
And it said,
today is a victory over yourself.
Of yesterday to Morrow is evictees your victory over lesser foes.
Fuck yeah.
Badass Samurai quotes.
That's what I'm talking about.
Pitch.
All right,
Joe Rosis here.
Why fuck around on at.com oh ending and it,
that's it.
He's a codeword Rogan save money.
I save 10% off any nail supplements with the codeword.
Rogan has.
Brian tries to start the music
to me.
Do you know how to do it?
Yeah,
it's not working for some reason.
Maybe because you weren't ready.
Here we go.
[inaudible]
wow.
That's the worst one ever.
Congratulations.
I didn't think you could fuck it up any more than that.
I mean it started off bad.
The middle was bad.
There was fucking two of them playing at the same time and it ended abruptly.
Everything was wrong.
Congratulations.
If you did that in a movie,
if you planned out the worst intro music for a podcast and a movie,
you fucking,
it sounded like you just took a random part out of like a prime.
Is it sound like a snippet from a prime song where it would have made sense in
the whole picture,
but just this,
the clip you're like,
it doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
Well it's a kind of funny story that one up getting resolved.
But Jamie called me the other day to tell me that one of my videos got taken
down from the Internet because someone used my words like my voice in a song and
then copywrote it.
Really?
Yeah.
The cop wrote my voice.
So when my voice,
the original version of that was online,
they put a copyright hit against me for my own voice.
That is unbelievable.
It was so hilarious.
I mean,
it got resolved.
Like when I started tweeting about it,
like,
what the fuck man?
Like this,
I don't know the details.
I don't know what to do.
And was thinking how he thought he could copyright my own voice.
What was his song?
It's like,
I don't know.
I didn't even listen to the song.
I heard the beginning of it where it sounds,
you know,
you,
there's a video that this guy,
um,
did,
uh,
called
American.
What is it called?
The American war machine.
American war machine.
Paradigm shift on Youtube.
Really cool guy.
I met him in Vancouver.
Very nice guy.
Very talented guy too.
Did this video.
It's really
cool.
It's a,
it's combining a bunch of rats with all this video of war stuff and the stuff
about us history and how crazy the military industrial complexes and the
beginning of it is this,
this rant that this guy took and put on a song.
Then it copywrote it
like he didn't even change the fucking music that my friend Tosh had put on the
thing.
He didn't even change it.
He just took that chunk,
put it in his song and then said,
this is mine.
It's like the shittiest version of buying a domain name to resell it.
I own your domain name.
Pepsi Spice.
Ah,
Brian owned Pepsi Spice Dotcom.
You remember when Pepsi Spice came out?
This is one of his best pranks.
I swear to God.
I thought it was one of the spice girls when you said that,
I didn't know what the fuck is.
Pepsi,
Pepsi spice was this horrendous idea.
It's like someone decided to like,
let's make Pepsi but spicy,
like a spicy Pepsi.
So here's a Thanksgiving for Thanksgiving because that's still up.
Is it up anywhere?
Can you see your all that stuff that he did,
pieces of it.
Damn Dude,
you got to put that up in a blog.
You should put put it up in a blog and we'll,
I think we shot it with a heart with a gun.
Oh,
did we?
Will we blew up the hard drive?
This is what he did.
Let me,
I'll tell,
I'll tell you the whole story.
He took Pepsi spice.com he bought the domain name because this is in like,
what was it like 2000 it was a long time.
10 years ago or something like that.
It might've been earlier.
It might've been before.
Fearful.
I don't think you were working for me,
man.
No,
I was just right when I moved here.
Okay,
so this is what he did.
He bought Pepsi spice.com before they did and then he started putting up a daily
blog about how he's eating nothing but Pepsi has placed,
his health was rapidly deteriorating.
He's hysterical.
Cataclysmic ways.
It was so funny,
man.
We were going to it every day and the Pepsi Spice people were fucking shitting
their pants
and it was before anyone understood the internet.
No high level executives in Pepsi or any of those major corporations.
There were very few of them understood the Internet.
If they did,
they would've bought Pepsi spice.com way before they were leaving.
But they didn't break his fucking blog up about him shitting blood and he's down
to 120 pounds now it's open when it's one of the things that you said you
remember,
I remember I had open sores everywhere and I was really good at Photoshop back
then said no one even knew that there was fake photos with as much,
you know,
so I had like pictures of me but these big bloody things,
I was hanging out with Lindsay Lohan snorting mushrooms like it was called
Mccain where we would like crush up mushrooms and snort.
I love it.
So,
so ridiculous.
Would you,
would you write the blog like,
like if you were like,
like the way a stranded island diary like day 36 I did.
It was just,
it was,
cause it was after soup,
that movie super size me.
So I pretty much just made it like this.
Like the seventh day I,
I've,
I'm starting to cough up a lot of stomach acid and stuff like that.
And then it just got worse
and worse.
And I think I ended up dying at the end.
I never finished it because did they ever buy the domain from,
you know,
I owned it for a while,
but then after a while you have a domain that no one even knows what Pepsi
spices anymore.
But yeah,
like here's what,
I never purchased it from you or told you to take it down now because they
stopped selling Pepsi spice.
I didn't mean anything.
Here's,
here's what,
here's some of it that
I can't read it.
It's blurry on that cane.
And then I just finished my last two liter,
got to skip will keep for health reasons.
It was really funny,
man.
That's really great.
It was really funny,
man.
It was all,
I got clogged armpits,
so that was one I
couldn't sweat.
Oh,
that's great.
I was believable.
Like nothing was too over the top.
At first effort.
It seems so normal.
And then as his journal got deeper and deeper,
it got more and more fucks up.
I love it.
It was really ridiculous.
That's incredible.
And it was,
it was a spicy,
it was a holiday spice.
She not like a buffalo wing.
Yeah,
right.
It was like a cinema need kind of a thing yet too much ginger.
So it was nasty.
I hate spiced anything.
I think spiced rum is like if I'm drinking with somebody and they're like,
I'll take a captain and coke.
I'm just like,
get out of my face.
You fucking idiot.
You gave me the other day at the icehouse that's super spicy liquor shot that we
did.
What the hell was that?
Oh,
fireball.
Fireball.
Yeah.
Disgusting.
I kind of like,
it's great and it is great because you know,
you take one before you hit the road and it's like you,
your how it helps your breath and everything.
Yeah,
yeah.
Just keep showing the glove compartment for you.
Get pulled over.
I mean,
you know,
hold on a second officer.
Yet people think that that stuff makes your breath taste good,
but basically anything that's alcohol makes you bread,
tastes like shit because once it goes in your stomach,
your stomach is like,
what is this?
And that's when the disgusting breath comes up.
I don't like any of those.
Like here's the weird part.
I love Jaeger Meister Jaeger masters.
My favorite shot on the planet earth.
Jaeger bombs like the white trash and I truly am really Jaeger bombs are my
favorite shot.
[inaudible] planet.
What do we have here right now?
Jimmy?
Let's do some shots.
Oh my God,
I'm off the booze.
Are you totally a hundred percent not forever.
I have fatty liver right now,
so I had to stop drinking.
All right,
we won't do shit.
God Damn it.
You guys can do one though.
Brian and I will do one shot.
Oh,
what you're doing.
You want to do one Jamie?
All right,
Jamie,
let's,
we're going to really regret not doing this with you in a week when I fall off
the wagon,
drank with the guys like what's fatty liver?
I mean just fat in your liver and it happen probably from drinking and eating
poorly for all these years.
I mean this is,
this was my,
I mean the,
and I'm not in great shape.
This is the best I've ever been in right now.
Like what?
You see?
Funny.
Why you laughing?
This demand is making progress.
And Brian's like,
yeah,
this is,
this is the best shape I've ever been in a,
which isn't saying much,
but uh,
I mean for years,
dude,
for years,
like my lifestyle was get completely shit faced four or five nights a week,
go home,
get,
and I would do this night after night,
get like a double meat cheese,
steak,
Doritos chocolate cake and a soda and literally lay in my bed,
wasted eating it and just pass out.
I would do that night after night after night I smoked,
you know,
it was,
it was just,
I think after a while,
you know,
I dabbled in the drugs here and there,
I think after a while it just kind of a little bit,
little bit,
but it catches up.
I'll try some Jamison since it's got a bunch of signatures on it.
Who wrote,
who signed on that thing?
Oh,
it's Christ.
You're brought it over your rights on the bottle.
So,
you know,
getting your hammered.
Um,
New York is kind of like that though,
right?
New York is a place where a lot of people already,
and I were talking about this last night,
people go out after the shows and they drink.
It's fucking greatest.
I missed it dude.
It was such an adventure,
man.
It was such an adventure.
I remember having nights in New York,
we're literally at like,
you do a set,
it'd be a Tuesday and you do a set,
you'd finish,
it'd be like nine 30 you'd be like,
that's Tuesday.
It's,
there's nothing going on.
This is,
this is done.
I'm going to go home.
And then somebody would be like,
hey,
you know though,
I heard so and so might be having a little,
do you want to just go over real quick and just check out what's happening?
You know,
across the,
you know,
across the way at the such and such bar.
And you'd go over and the next thing you know,
dude,
it's 5:00 AM and there's been,
you know,
blow and whiskey and you're wasted and you're fucking a girl and it's greatest
man.
Fuck that sounds good.
It's the greatest [inaudible] below and I want to do it now.
He just like,
where did this come from?
It's just that never happens in la.
Oh yes it does.
You need to hang around at the comedy store.
You fucking crazy.
When does a wild night happen out here?
You gotta drive Goddamn home every night.
You can't,
oh,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
It's a different animal.
And the bars close at two,
you know,
it's,
it's definitely a different animal.
But like,
uh,
I mean Dan was like the whole deal about the store was coke,
right?
I mean those,
the Kennison days.
I talked to Martin again last night cause Marin was at a,
Ari's a TV show taping our,
he's got a new TV show on comedy central called this is not happening.
Yeah,
I know.
And Marin did a story last night and him and I talked again about the Kennison
days about doing blow with Kennison to the point where he heard voices in his
head for a year.
She uses Christ Christ.
What the fuck
kid.
He was a young kid hanging out at the store and he was partying with Kinison and
working at the store,
you know?
And
that's the difference between,
and I'm not trying to shit on ally,
but that's different city la drugs in New York drugs,
New York drugs are like wolf of Wall Street.
Hey,
it's a fucking party for it.
We're at the beach,
we're going to the Hamptons,
right.
A Bar,
Go and pass out,
get up,
hit your job tomorrow.
La Drugs are,
it's like,
feels like river Phoenix.
There's a darkness,
there's a darkness to it.
It's something.
There's something like out to here that feels much more like stripper fucking cc
does
bill,
you know bill,
he pulls out a poison reference.
Yeah,
it's,
I don't know and I'm not,
I'm not doing it in New York versus La thing,
but like it's different for sure.
New York.
Did it feel like that New York just felt way more just like,
like age in the neighborhood?
Right.
Fuck it.
He never lived in the city.
So I didn't get that thing out of New York because when I first moved to New
York I needed a car because I was doing road gigs and the only way I can make a
living was to do the road.
Like I couldn't do the whole 15 shows in a night,
like do a seven minute spot here and seven and then add up the $10,
whatever the fuck you would get from each set.
Cause a lot,
a lot like a tell you to do that.
He would do 10 15 sets a night,
all these little seven minute sets and run all over the place and do it and just
take cabs and stuff.
And that was life.
But I,
I was getting these road gigs and that was the only way I was paying my money or
paying my bill.
So I lived in new Rochelle.
So for me I didn't do that,
that whole live in the city.
Take cabs or take the subway everywhere.
I could totally get that though.
Oh Dude,
it was,
yeah,
it was just yet New York,
New York.
Like when you live because I lived all over New York for nine years.
I was,
I started in Queens,
then it was up in Harlem and Harlem.
Fuck.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Not because of Harlem,
just because,
talk to daddy.
What do you want to know?
I've bagged them all shapes and sizes.
Powerful.
John,
Jada Rosa kept the kids get around.
What's your favorite spot to live?
Uh,
I had a great time in every place that I lived.
My least favorite was queens,
not because of Queens,
but I had a fun time in Queens.
I lived with Jay Oakerson out there and it was fun,
but we lived in like a very,
he was,
he was like living with his baby's mother at the time and they had a kid and I
was living with them,
which was fine.
It was actually very nice,
but we were in it like a very like sort of neighborhood.
He suburban part of Queens.
There wasn't anything you could like walk to or do.
So that's the only reason I didn't like it.
Um,
Harlem was fun because it was my first time being on the island and it was wild.
I these Irish neighbors,
and I mean any night of the week you just knock on their door and it,
you know,
and it's 4:00 AM and they know,
oh did,
it was nuts.
It was fucking crazy.
The Irish and they were crazy.
They were so crazy.
Rachel,
who's one of my close friends and a really funny comic and obviously Jewish,
I brought her out one night.
One of the Irish guys used to live next door to it.
I'm like,
you're gonna love this guy.
He's great.
He's nuts.
And we're hanging out for a while at this bar.
And she comes over to me.
She's like,
okay,
I'm going to go.
And I go,
why?
And she's like,
you're Irish friend is telling me that the numbers of the Holocaust were greatly
exaggerated.
That's he a Irish from Ireland.
Is that no,
so high.
The fucking Jews is a little bit,
a bunch of laser,
but just shite.
He wasn't saying it like that.
He was,
well,
he wasn't saying it like,
like you fucking liars.
There was some somehow a strange sense of sympathy in his voice as he was also
saying he thought the numbers were exaggerated,
but,
but it was,
the point is,
is that he was just a fucking lunatic.
There was no filter on his brain.
He wasn't saying it like,
God dammit,
I'm sick of hearing about it.
It was just shit would just leak out of his mouth,
you know?
He was saying it like,
have you ever really thought about it?
Let's think about.
It's like,
no,
let's not think about it.
Like let's just not talk about it.
That's when you can't fuck with no
dude sent me this fucking email.
Can you refute this video with this?
Whenever someone sends you a youtube video on anything,
you got to go,
okay,
is there,
is there other shit out there?
Are there
books?
Have scientists look at this and scholars study this.
He sent me a youtube video.
You know I'm going to,
I'm going to listen to it,
but since I'm not an expert on the Holocaust,
I dunno what the fuck exactly what's wrong in this video.
But it was like they're talking about different places.
Couldn't be actually used for gas chambers and it was bullshit.
They actually,
a guy ruined his career because of this.
I watched that documentary death.
That documentary is amazing.
Fantastic documentary.
It's called Dr Death.
And it's about this guy who was a,
he was an engineer for these execution devices and these,
I don't know,
let's,
you know,
holocaust deniers,
holocaust revisionists,
whatever you'd want to call them.
I mean,
I don't think they were denying the Holocaust,
but they were saying that it was exaggerated.
Yeah.
And this guy went over there and because of these people,
he gave this really fucked up,
inaccurate,
unscientific assessment of certain famous sites.
We're fucking,
hundreds of thousands of people documented were murdered.
And he was saying that it couldn't have happened.
And then it just,
his,
you know,
he went to court over that.
Yeah.
And then he lost his family.
It was his whole life.
It was,
it.
He was devastated.
It can be wrong about now.
No,
you don't want to roll the dice on the Holocaust,
but you know what I mean?
It's
man,
you know what's fucked.
There's other holocausts that people don't even know about like the Armenian
genocide,
right.
Like I didn't even know about the Armenian genocide is a true story until I was
in the octagon interviewing Manny GAM Burean and I think you could tell by Manny
Gambhir Ian's name,
he might be Armenian and man,
he's uh,
you know,
great MMA fighter and uh,
he's,
you know,
he's very proud to be from Armenia and was talking about the anniversary.
It was like he,
he won on the anniversary of the Armenian genocide and he was talking about
like,
like raising awareness for Armenian genocide.
And I was like,
I didn't even know what this is.
And then I looked into it.
It's just fucking horrible.
Horrible.
I didn't know about that either.
Million dead.
I mean,
it just terrible,
terrible,
terrible story.
Yeah.
I was driving,
I live on the east side and I was driving,
I was riding on a TV show for a little while and I was driving to work one
morning and I couldn't get to work because there was so much traffic and I was
just like,
what the fuck is going on?
It's,
it's 9:45 AM on Hollywood boulevard.
Why is this so backed up?
And then I saw people like walking around with these shirts on that said our
wounds are still open.
And um,
I feel like a real,
I know I'm an asshole before I say this.
I thought it was some kind of record release
and I was getting so mad.
I thought like a rapper,
like a release day is going on.
It was still open.
Our mouth,
I'll close is moving.
I rustled my toes.
Oh
my teeth is gold.
You're trying to buy my album.
But the shit's already sold out.
Free style.
2014.
Well,
much love.
Guess what?
That's not what it was,
dude.
It was
the anniversary of the Armenian genocide because I was driving through little
Armenia and I didn't know.
And then I got to work and somebody was like,
this is what this is.
And I was like,
oh Jesus,
bad man.
It's scary shit man.
When you hear about stuff like that and you're like,
wait a minute.
That was 1915 1915 Armenian civilians escorted by armed Ottoman soldiers are
marched through,
uh,
to a prison in nearby Mesos rich present day.
[inaudible] it's impossible to pronounce it in 1915 between 1000001.5 million
people were murdered.
Wow.
Yeah.
24th of April,
now do you think the other ones don't get mentioned like this one for instance,
because they,
they are so small in size compared to the number of deaths with the Jewish
Holocaust.
I Dunno cause Jewish how close like 6 million.
This is a 1.5 which is a ton of people.
But I mean,
you know,
I don't know.
I wonder if that's why it gets,
they all get so overshadowed.
It's so good
question.
I mean,
I don't look,
it's anytime it's,
that's a lot of fucking people.
1.5 million people.
I can't imagine how it could ever be overshadowed.
I just say I'm ashamed that I learned about it while I was talking to somebody.
Yeah,
well that's,
that's even,
that's why I asked the question because it's like I don't even,
I can't justify in my head how something like that would get overshadowed other
than I guess maybe this other one was so much bigger.
I don't know,
man.
It's
because the Jews control the media.
Jill.
I know how to spread a story.
It's kind of like when like,
you know when Farrah Fawcett died with the Michael Jackson time the same day,
he got all the press and they died in the same day.
They die back on the same day and Farrah Fawcett got nothing.
Remember that?
Poor Fair.
No.
It's a trait parallel to draw,
but even fucking he kids allegedly,
no,
I know.
I'm not convinced he did still.
I'm still not convinced you.
I have a theory.
It's a very bad theory.
I'm going to tell you right now,
if you're Joe Rome is a moron.
I agree with you.
Okay.
I'm on your side.
I think I'm more on too,
but I think there's a possibility that he might have been what they call a cast
Strada.
Do you know what a cast Trotta is?
No Caste Strada music,
I think I'm saying it right,
is a type of music where they would castrate young boys and they would castrate
young boys so that they would sing this incredible pitch.
That didn't sound manly at all.
It's very bizarre.
It's very freaky.
You can hear it on,
why haven't we played it on the podcast before?
Let's play some just for Derosa so cause he's never heard it before.
Okay.
But there's a style of music that was created by castrating boys because when
you're moved their testicles,
they don't produce testosterone and they have this weird sort of,
you know,
it's this,
I'm androgynous sort of sound to their voice and it's,
uh,
it's,
it's feminine,
but like a little bit masculine.
And it's very similar to how Michael Jackson is.
Have you seen Michael Jackson's brothers?
Yeah.
They look manly as fuck.
And they sound manly.
Yeah.
They sound manly.
He stayed really slender.
He stayed like a guy who had no testosterone.
He didn't look like a man who had testosterone.
He was Rick,
really slender.
I think this is a great theory.
It's not a bad theory.
I think it might have happened to me by the way.
Well,
it's also the thing about these men or these,
these,
they're men now,
but the,
they say that they were molested by Michael Jackson.
No one says he fucked them.
No,
it was all like weird touching stuff.
Yeah,
and I,
I don't,
I don't think there was anything going on there.
I think that's why he longed for childhood needs a terrible theory.
Again,
I'll tell you right now,
it's not backed by any facts.
I don't think it's a terrible theory.
But listen,
this is a cast Strada.
This is a long time ago,
by the way.
This is like ninth was in 19 early 19 hundreds these recordings,
I mean you don't do this anymore unless I don't know about it,
but there's,
there's something to Michael Jackson's voice when you listen to the way he would
sing that.
Fuck man,
that doesn't sound like any guy I've ever heard.
No,
no.
It's why tell him that it's human nature.
I guess she didn't feel that way.
I tried to do thriller once a Karaoke and I almost shit a fucking aneurysm.
Yeah,
it's so high.
It's so like you can't try to sing it.
Try to sing the chorus
without
the bat strike.
Yes,
but do it without doing the false shadow.
Just try.
I can't fucking sing anyway.
Okay.
Here's this terrible,
here we go.
Because
no,
I can't say,
well,
I can't do anything else.
That's it.
I can't say it's impossible.
It's impossible to hit those notes like it's dude,
it's past Getty Lee [inaudible].
It's like way past.
Ready leave.
Well,
Getty Lee,
who I love still sounds like an odd man.
I love rush.
But when you listen to like living in the limelight,
please singing that song.
He sounds like an odd man.
It doesn't sound like something that can't be achieved when you hear Michael
Jackson saying,
you go,
something's going on here and I should have fucking put my finger on it.
It's not,
it's not mail.
No.
Yeah,
it sounds womanly and that's forever been the joke about him.
I think there might be something to my stupid theory and I think it's because I
have this connection with,
I have this like weird thing about him because I've always wanted to know like
what makes a person want to stay a child?
Because I've always been accused,
rightly so,
of being immature.
I'm very immature,
but it's almost on purpose,
right?
Because when I grew up,
I saw these people that were mature,
that we're living these mature lives and they were fucking miserable man.
They,
they suffered all day.
There was no reward that came home to a wife.
They hated,
they lived a shit life and a lot of them died young.
I just,
I saw it in front of me.
I didn't want to do that.
So I,
I tried to figure out every way I could to rebel against work.
And I remember seeing like this guy and seeing Michael Jackson how brilliant he
was,
but how odd it was and how he always had like these amusement park rides at his
house and invited little kids over.
And I'm like,
what was wrong?
It's beautiful that the guy wanted to help kids.
It's beautiful.
The guy always work with these people that were sick and these kids that were
dying.
It is beautiful.
But what was it that connected him so much to childlike things?
Like why was he so child?
Like why did he never have,
I mean,
he had children,
but they weren't really his children.
There were white kids there.
They're fully white kids.
If you look at them today,
you can say,
well,
these didn't come from his DNA.
They might've been as children.
But yeah,
it's very odd.
It's very odd also how much his children are out of the limelight there.
There,
there's no connection with them to Michael Jackson.
None.
None whatsoever.
Which is good.
I mean,
they're just kids.
They don't,
you know,
they don't deserve it.
It,
I do think it is good,
but I mean,
even like with,
with other celebrities that attempted to keep the kid out of the spotlight,
like,
you know,
m and m doesn't,
aside from talking about her,
doesn't like put his daughter out there.
Uh,
and he's like staunchly opposed to it yet.
We all kind of know what she looks like.
We all know who she is.
Like if you saw her the same with the Cobain and Courtney
love's kid.
Um,
but Michael Jackson,
it's like I couldn't pick those kids out of a fucking lineup.
Well,
that's good.
I hope that that's because the family sheltered the kids from all the crazy
people that,
I mean,
you want to talk crazy people.
Michael Jackson was a star on a level that we can't even begin to comprehend.
I mean,
this is a guy who couldn't leave the fucking house.
If he left the fucking house,
there would be a swarm of people.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I met a girl one more round,
sir.
He's,
yes,
Brian,
you're going in would be a pussy.
I knew a girl that,
uh,
that new a Brittany Spears.
Whoa.
Like in recent years.
I mean,
and she was,
I was like,
what's she like?
And she goes,
she goes,
she's really down to earth.
She goes,
she's really cool considering especially who she is.
And she was like,
dude,
she literally can't go anywhere in the entire world without being known.
Like I can't even fathom that.
Stan hope is buddies with Johnny Depp.
Yeah,
Johnny Depp Sustain Hope.
Then Johnny Depp contact to Stan hope about some project and got together and
started hanging out with them in England and he realized when they were hanging
out,
I was like,
he goes,
oh,
I can't go anywhere.
Like you can't,
he can't go anywhere.
It doesn't go anywhere.
He has brings a chef over to his home when he was over at his house.
Um,
uh,
not Keith Richards.
Who's in the rolling stones?
Keith Richards,
Jagger,
Mick Jagger.
The other one was the other one.
I don't know who the fuck is in the rolling stones.
Who's the other guy?
Ron Wood.
Is that his name?
Shit.
What did we retarded?
How do we not know who's trying to remember the drummer's name and I can't
remember his name.
Yeah,
I'm trying to,
okay.
Rollingstones who the fuck is in the rolling stones?
God,
isn't that funny?
You only remember Keith Richards.
I was never a big stones guy,
so I barely on the a bolt of you.
I love the logo though with the lips or the tongue or whatever the fuck was on
their website.
They just expect you to know who the fuck everybody is.
Back in the day that was sex sexual,
I was a kid growing up.
It's so weird kid.
The logos,
what stopped me from getting into the logos where it stopped for me.
Uh,
you know what?
I should shut the fuck up right here because I probably shouldn't even say what
happened.
I was about,
I'd probably,
it's probably good.
Okay.
Ron Wood,
that is his name.
Anyway,
the point is there were all hanging out and Stan hope realized,
oh Johnny Depp is two famous.
He's gotten way too famous and apparently it was from those pirates of the
Caribbean movies.
From there on out,
there's no more going to restaurants.
Dude.
I when,
when Chappelle came back from Africa,
when he went,
when he like,
you know,
ran off from the TV show and everything and when he came back he went on this
tour and I toured with them.
And I know Dave isn't,
you know,
Johnny Depp,
but he's pretty fucking famous,
you know,
and uh,
he,
uh,
it was crazy man,
because we were doing these shows and I was opening for him for like two weeks
and he'd literally just be like,
when I go to the mall,
man,
and I'd be like,
yeah,
let's go.
He'd be like,
all right,
let's go.
And literally I would walk to the mall with Dave Chappelle,
no security,
nothing.
And cars were screeching in the fucking streets.
People were jumping out of their cars.
They were running up to,
we went to a footlocker in the mall.
We had to leave through the back exit because so many people were flooding in
because he was,
and I was,
the worst part was we went a pack of people followed us to the hotel.
Hip fouled him.
I was just there.
Uh,
but a pack of people like fucking dogs follow him
to the hotel.
Like I'm telling it all going,
I'm Rick James Bitch.
Yes,
yes.
They were backwards.
Baseball hats on.
Yeah.
No,
it's all,
it's all like,
it was like a lot of like fat white guys and uh,
and uh,
they fought us.
There was like 30 people.
I'm not exaggerating.
We got to the hotel,
the,
the concierge at the hotel had to literally hold the people back so we could get
onto the hotel or the elevator.
And as the doors were shutting,
a guy got around the concierge and ran up and literally put his phone almost
against Chappelle's face and goes,
say something funny.
My friends on the phone say something funny and Dave just kind of stared at this
guy and we got on the elevator and the doors shut.
And I go,
dude,
I don't know how you didn't just lay that dude out,
man.
That was like the rudest thing I've ever seen anybody do to a person.
And he was just like,
what are you going to do man?
That's,
that's why we're doing the time.
Why you need to stay high when you're that famous all day.
But he gave me the best advice ever,
uh,
that ever gotten comedy.
And I t I talk about this in my act a little bit like the,
I tell the story,
but we were hanging out after we did a show one night in Cleveland at the,
at this big amphitheater and after the show I'm talking to these two girls and
they're like,
you're so funny.
And I'm like,
once you come back to the hook towel,
yeah,
come hang out.
Dave might stop by.
You know,
I was trying to say that.
Yeah,
yeah.
I was trying to pick up these chicks.
He actually wasn't going to stop by the imagine if you were in the middle of
boner and she heard Dave's voice and just like get off me.
Yeah,
exactly.
Imagine me,
his cock blocking anybody standing in the living room.
I'm Rick James Bitch.
Oh my God.
Is it hell
I need to meet him.
He's not going anywhere.
I'm coming 30 seconds.
He was awesome.
No rape.
He was an awesome wing man cause he was,
he was,
he's married and he was like a great dude about it.
He was just like,
you know,
he would sit there and like talk to you.
You know,
with the chicks and then like he'd peel off and then you'd be there with the
checks.
Man,
it was fucking beautiful.
And the chicks would go,
you must be special.
Oh Dude.
Well they also just saw you open for dude,
it was so,
oh,
look at you.
You're glowing.
There's really,
it was nice.
It was nice.
It was really nice.
So I was talking to these two girls after one of the shows in Cleveland and,
uh,
and I'm like,
come back to the hotel and they're,
they're being wishy washy.
And I'm like,
all right,
whatever.
And they take my number and I,
I go backstage
and I'm bitching to Dave and the,
the tour bus driver about the checks.
And I'm like,
you know,
they fucking just being on wishy washy and I don't know this and I don't know,
it's just annoying.
Just fucking hanging out.
If you're gonna hang out and the bus driver goes,
Joe,
I'm a tell you what you need to do,
man.
You need to walk up to that girl,
look her dead in the eye and say,
do you want to suck my Dick or not?
Right?
And I was like,
terrible advice.
I was like,
okay,
okay.
And uh,
I was considering it for a second and then Chappelle goes,
don't do that shit man.
Don't do it.
You're going to fuck around Joe.
You're going to get famous one of these days.
10 years from now,
that bitch will be on hardcopy going,
Joe Derosa told me to suck his dick and Cleveland once.
Well,
the reality is even if that didn't happen,
there's going to be a girl if you get famous,
that just remembers a story that never happened at all about Joe Derosa toner to
suck your cock,
right?
Right.
I've had fucking people tell me stories about me that absolutely didn't exist.
That never happened really about at fucking on the podcast.
Remember crash was telling a story about a fight in New York that never took
place about how I told this guy,
can you handle that guy?
I'll take the other two.
And I went over and kicked some guy in the head.
Never happened.
None of it happened real.
He was like arguing with me.
That happened.
I'm like,
dude,
I am telling you I didn't.
I haven't fought anybody since.
I haven't had a street fight since I was in high school.
All right.
I've avoided every single physical altercation outside of competition since high
school.
So this never happened.
It's impossible that it happened.
And it's a great like rumor though about your makes you sound like a killer
sound like an asshole.
I don't think it makes you sound like an answer.
Totally makes me sound like an asshole.
Listen,
whenever you see a bunch of people and you're like,
could you took dot I'll ticket,
why won't you just turn around,
get the fuck out of there.
That's the smart move.
The smart guy walks out of there.
I see.
I'm,
I'm a little fucking whisper.
Grasp that.
That can't fight at all.
Most fucking the weakest thing you ever been scanned up straight.
That's such a funny
of grass.
I remember seeing a tail once onstage and uh,
there were,
there were three fat girls in the front row or no,
there was two,
I think it was two fingers and a fat girl in the middle.
And I don't remember why he said this to the fat girl,
but it was something about how she didn't think she was fat.
And he goes,
oh,
I know,
right?
You look at just sitting there like a little blade of grass,
a little blade of grass.
I think he's fat shaming that's outlawed now.
So cool guy on the Internet,
fat shaming is fucking mail.
Hypocrisy slash patriarchy slash privilege lash.
Keep going.
Uh,
I,
but I,
so I'm,
I would love a story like that.
I would like,
my point is,
is I'm a pussy.
I would love to be in a situation where I literally go,
I can take this guy.
Can you take that guy?
I would just never be in that situation.
People make stuff up like that.
Things that never happened.
I take,
since
I had a guy come up to me at a party and he goes,
my Dennis played golf with you.
And I go,
no,
it wasn't me goes,
oh yeah,
you're the guy from fear factor.
My dentist played golf with you.
I go dude,
I've never played golf ever in my whole life.
I've never played golf.
It's pride that other Rogan that that sports newscaster and it's just like
probably not.
I mean he probably plays golf.
Fred Rogan.
Yeah,
maybe it might be,
but he was insisting it was the fear factor guy.
He was insisting.
Yeah,
it's a,
I don't know man.
I Dunno if I ever reach your level.
Like I'll be able to relate to these stories.
I wish I had rumors floating around about me.
I got nothing going on right.
As rumors from high school.
That never happened.
That I talked to a friend who knew a friend of mine from high school things that
happened that never happened.
Like what?
It's just violent things.
Mostly violent things.
You always this guy like a,
like a cut fucking MMA type dude.
Well in the hot from high school on I did martial arts like pretty religiously.
That was my whole life from like 15 on.
Am I crazy?
Cause I remember when,
see when I would see you on news radio,
I don't remember you being jack like this though,
where you cut up like that.
It was a whole videos and me taking my shirt off,
I had to wrestle Andy.
Dick wants and fucking number that find that.
Yeah.
I wasn't as big.
I didn't really lift weights until I started doing Jujitsu and I started doing
Jujitsu in 96 so that was when I started lifting weights and I started hanging
out with Eddie Bravo,
my,
my good friend Eddie Bravo,
my best friend.
Like we're around 99 2000 somewhere around then.
And we started lifting weights pretty seriously right after that cause I started
really getting into Jujitsu.
Okay.
And one of the things about Jujitsu is just protecting your joints and
protecting your back and protecting your neck and all these different parts of
your body and that adding muscle to your body keeps you from getting injured.
It's kind of important.
Okay.
And also gives you more strength to execute moves.
It's just like Jujitsu is a very,
very grueling activity and the stronger you are,
I mean it's good.
It's most important to be technical to understand the technique,
but the stronger you are the better.
So I started lifting weights pretty seriously around that.
So this is me when I didn't even lift weights.
Yeah.
This was like,
was this from the show?
This is from news radio.
Yeah.
I like how I asked that.
No,
it's a real match between you and Andy Dick.
That's what I look like with no weight lifting at all.
That was just kickboxing.
Jesus,
that was pretty good.
Yeah.
But then you click it tickles me and kicks my ass
like I would,
I was just about to say the same thing to you.
Chat.
All right dude.
That's it.
Yeah,
it is.
It tick,
tick.
It's so stupid.
Shut it off now how dare you.
So
I liked that show.
Yeah.
That was like probably 1990 it was Phil was alive.
So it was before 90 s I think he was murdered in 98.
[inaudible] four that was probably 97 96 so no,
there was no lifting weights back then.
It was just the kickboxing.
Jesus,
man,
you were ripped,
dude.
Still are.
You want to talk about it?
I got nothing.
I got nothing to it.
I think I have any thing to say about,
well,
I went,
you know,
I don't understand it.
I don't mean that in a derogatory way.
That was my life.
I went down a different path,
you know,
like uh,
I don't understand.
I have a friends that do extreme sports,
you know,
like do they do like a,
the jumped bikes and shit like that and motorbikes and stuff like that and do
flips and they're all busted up and like,
I know this dude Eric Apple,
his wrist is,
he broke his wrist so bad.
It's like an inch shorter.
That's like,
he's out.
Like all the ligaments.
Which any anyone on from that to do MMA fighting?
She's just crazy,
crazy people.
Like he's crying.
That's how he grew up.
You know,
I literally grew up doing martial arts competition.
So that was my,
I mean,
it made me a way more balanced person,
if that makes any sense.
I would have worked way more fucked up given my circumstances.
I needed something to throw all my energy and I just had so much anger and
anxiety and insecurity.
I needed something and I found it in martial arts,
but it just happened to be the thing for me at that time.
So that's why,
you know,
it's not like it makes perfect sense.
It's not for everybody.
You know?
It can help you though if you're looking for something to do,
to give you some physical exercise.
And also it gives you a kind of understanding of your,
your body and fear.
I wish I had a,
I wish I had been pushed in that direction at a younger age,
at a young age.
Uh,
because I'm too old for it now.
And I told you I'm 37.
My friend's dad started doing Jujitsu when he was 57.
Really got his black belt.
I think it was like 65 or 66.
He got his black belt.
Yeah.
Maybe I should,
I don't know.
I have such terrible anxiety and angst issue still.
And yeah,
like therapy for it and stuff.
But
the main,
I mean if you want to talk about this,
but sure.
Do you have a main fear of thing that fucks with you?
Uh,
my fear of death is pretty,
uh,
tremendous,
pretty tremendous and extremely irrational.
Um,
it's,
it's almost crippling.
It's almost crippling.
Wow.
Have you done any psychedelics,
like heavy doses of mushrooms or heavy doses of yeah,
I dunno what heavy doses are,
but I mean,
I,
you know,
I've,
I took my share of mushrooms and acid through the years,
uh,
but in your hand and show me what's the biggest dose you've ever taken?
You know,
like,
no,
that's not good enough.
Sun,
you showing me a little tiny quarter
size,
you know,
I remember tripping for like 11,
12 hours on acid,
like stuff like that.
I don't have any experience with acid,
but I do have experience with mushrooms and my experiences that there's a big
difference between like a couple of caps and stems and a fucking handful.
It's a handful.
You want like five grams.
Oh,
you do the,
when you do like those big trips,
that's when you just go.
It just obliterates your ego and you,
you go just deep into the realm of perception and of understanding your position
in this great thing that you see in front of you and how much your position in
this great thing,
this great thing being the entire universe itself.
How much of your position is distorted by your own ability to recognize your
surroundings and your need to survive.
And then your ego,
which comes into place and wants you to get laid,
wants you to be fed,
wants you to stay alive and competitive.
Like all those variables they fuck with your,
your ability to understand the true nature of reality and sometimes a real ego
obliterating experience is what you need just to kind of put it in place.
See the problem is now for me,
I had some brushes with that in my time that I would do these heavier
psychedelics.
Uh,
but my problem is now is that my anxiety is such an issue that I wouldn't be
able to handle it.
Wow.
I can't even handle pot now.
I mean,
if I went into a hard trip like that,
I would start freaking out.
I turned to inward.
I'm a pretty lethargic guy,
so I've always been more of a fan of stimulants then.
Then barbiturates and depressants,
um,
which is what eventually pulled me away from marijuana because my problem with
marijuana is I'll smoke it and I go deep into my head and it's bad.
If I had,
if I had smoked any weed before I came in here today,
this would literally,
I would be panicking right now because I feel,
I feel a general anxiety just being here.
Yeah.
Why,
what is the general anxiety?
Just anytime you're talking to people or that you're online?
Um,
I have,
I definitely have,
uh,
you know,
self esteem issues and,
and um,
uh,
excuse me,
a issues about my own achievement and worth.
So when I do something like this for the first time,
um,
I'm,
I got the first few times,
uh,
I am nervous because unlike,
don't fuck it up.
Don't fuck this up.
This is a guy you don't know.
You know,
cause I don't really know you.
You know what I mean?
We,
we kind of
kind of,
but we're like,
I mean I consider you a like a comrade,
a colleague,
a fellow comic,
every comic that I know that's a comic.
Like you get sanctioned by Jimmy Norton or any of those guys that you're,
you're in your,
you can stay at my house.
I don't even know you.
But if you want to stay at my house,
he could stay at my house
and I,
that's how I feel.
Thank you.
And I honestly feel the same way about you and not because I've known you from
TV for longer than we've known each other personally.
Like I,
I feel the same way.
I feel like we're part of a fraternity and not just because of comedy,
but it's a little more specified for,
for us,
I think because we're part of the LNA camp and you know,
that's a special camp.
It was a special camp to be a part of.
So still
does he know?
I don't know if they're going to ever going to sort that out,
but it's not the same.
I love Jimmy and I love opie and they're great together and I listened to it all
the time,
but God dammit,
I Ms. Anthony.
It's,
it is,
it is a bummer.
It's a real bummer,
you know?
That's,
that's uh,
well,
let me answer your question.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
but,
but so I feel like,
you know,
every,
everything I do,
for instance right now in La,
and trust me,
it's not a terrible anxiety right now.
I was excited about this too.
Like a lot of it is just excitement and interpreting the excitement.
But,
um,
you know,
I'm doing that.
I'm doing a part of the TV show right now,
uh,
that looks like it might last for a little while.
I don't know yet because it's sort of episode episode,
but with something like that,
like every time I do it,
I'm like,
don't fuck this up dude.
This is your art.
You know what I mean?
And that's what I do and it's terrible.
It's a terrible,
terrible anxiety.
Um,
it doesn't prevent me from performing.
It doesn't prevent me from delivering,
but it's there and it's the kind of thing where if something does go wrong,
I have a very hard time just leaving it behind me and going,
it was a bad day at work,
dude,
let it go.
You know,
I did a charity event last night and it wasn't a great show and this was a huge
step for me today.
I woke up with anxiety about it at four 30 in the morning.
Why did you do this bit?
Why did you do that?
And I was just like,
dude,
you didn't do anything wrong.
You just weren't the best choice for that Gig.
That's it.
It's okay.
You didn't do anything wrong.
And I think most people go down that road first and my whole life,
I've never gone down that road first.
I go down the blaming myself road first.
Well,
let me be honest with you then.
Um,
I,
I've had shows where I had a great set for 90 minutes and I'll close badly,
fuck up something and I can't sleep.
I'll wake up in the middle of the night and I just,
in a hurricane,
a hurricane of anguish and being upset.
But I think that's because I care.
It's because I care.
Because I don't want anybody leaving a show ever and feeling like,
ah,
I don't ever want,
I know they paid money.
That drives me fucking crazy and terrible babysitters.
They planned it out.
They saved their money for that.
You know,
I don't want anyone to ever think that I ever take that for granted because that
would drive me fucking crazy if,
if I went to see someone and I knew they didn't give a shit and they took it for
granted,
that's one of the worst things that perform we can ever do with their audience.
It's disrespect their audience.
Right.
I brought this up before,
but I'll bring it up again.
It's what I call the Joe Dimaggio principle,
right?
Cause I remembered this quote when I was a kid,
Joe Dimaggio was like 40 years old,
sliding into third base and they,
the guy in the other team goes,
you know why you playing so hard?
You're already in the hall of fame.
And he goes,
cause someone out there is someone in the audience that hasn't seen Joe Dimaggio
play and I don't want to let them down.
That's so great.
Lori.
Lori Kilmartin said once to me years,
I was opening for her in Philadelphia.
And I said,
how do you,
how do you manage to go out and show the same enthusiasm every set?
Because I noticed throughout the weekend that she was doing that and I was
having a hard time with that at that point in my career.
And she said,
just think about it.
She's like,
you're a fan of comedy.
Haven't you ever seen a comedian that makes you laugh so hard you want to fall
over?
And I go,
yeah.
And she goes,
there's a chance somebody in the audience that's going to happen because of you
tonight.
You should always have that in your head.
And that's,
that's the Dimaggio thing you just said.
You know what I mean?
It's a lot of times it's just a perception issue.
Like how you deal with things.
Like,
um,
I had a friend that came up to me once,
uh,
we were in Vegas and uh,
I brought him to some fights and uh,
after the fights it gets pretty fucking crazy.
It's,
you know,
there's 18,000 people there and try to wake your way through the casino.
Good luck,
you know,
you're going to get stopped every five seconds.
And he was like,
does it get annoying?
I go,
well,
there's certain times where I have things that I have to do where I have to
leave.
Like I have to go to a show or I'm,
I have to meet someone for dinner.
I mean a half to be there by x amount of time.
I just have to say no.
But for the most part it's just a bunch of people being nice.
But my attitude about it is always that every time I meet someone I reset
because it's like,
I don't ever think of it as like,
oh,
here's another person,
here's another person.
Every time I meet someone I reset.
So it's a total new experience because I know it's a new experience for them.
And if I,
if I don't,
I don't accept that.
I can't always say yes.
I can't always call your friend.
I can't always fucking take picture.
I have to go sometimes,
like sometimes it's unavoidable,
there's a hundred people and you gotta be out of there because you're supposed
to be somewhere in five minutes.
I can't be late for a show.
I can't be late for an interview or an appearance and I have to do or whatever
the fuck that's right.
Yeah.
No,
and I think that reset mentality is great.
Like,
you know,
when I first started doing ona,
Burke told me years ago,
he was like,
listen,
here's what you do.
He goes,
you're doing the show now guys are gonna start coming out to see you.
You,
you sell your merch,
you shake everybody's hand.
And he goes and,
and talk and just talk.
He goes,
you know,
sometimes you can't spend a lot of time with everybody,
but talked to everybody,
say hello.
And he was like,
and that's what you do dude.
That like,
and,
and not that I would have done any different,
but him saying that really cemented it into my head.
He's a great guy.
Yeah.
And I've seen him do it and I've always done it if there are fucking two people
in the audience that wanted to see me,
and it was a shitty show of all time because there were 98 that didn't give a
fuck about who I was and heckling or whatever.
I spent time with those two guys and talk to them,
you know what I mean?
And I talked to them like,
Like,
like talking to you.
Yeah.
That's how it should be.
You know,
Burt said once that something that I thought was really cool,
he said,
uh,
we're were just talking about out,
everything's going really well for him and he's real happy.
And,
uh,
he sells,
you know,
I do.
I remember when I was a kid and,
uh,
I would,
I'd go see a band and then,
uh,
you know,
they're,
the new song sucked and I just wasn't into it.
They put on a bad show and it felt like they fucked me up.
And he goes,
and I know that if people come out to see me,
their fans,
and I'm not going to fuck them.
I'm not going to fuck him.
I'm going to,
I'm going to write hard.
I'm gonna work hard.
I'm going to get out there and give it my best.
I don't want to fuck them.
That's a great attitude.
It is.
I mean,
he,
he works,
he works so hard and he,
and he gives his,
he delivers to his fans what they deserve.
I think everybody,
excuse me,
many comics do that.
But I think again,
like what was always special to me about,
or one of the things that was always special to me about being part of that ONA
fraternity was that those comics all did that everybody delivered.
You know,
everybody had the mentality of it's a new year.
I have to go back to the,
to that city again.
I better have a new hour or it better be the much,
much better version of last year's hour cause I'm about to tape it or whatever
it is,
you know.
But uh,
and it was Patrice was like that obviously Norton uh,
uh,
Louis,
obviously you know,
like,
like these guys,
you know,
the,
you know for like that,
that's what they,
that's what they all did.
You know,
one of the great things about the opiate Anthony show was that it was a hangout.
Like even if like Ricky Gervais' came on or some big star came on,
if you and I were on the show,
we would still be on the show and then we'd sit in there and everybody knew to
lay back and let someone talk.
Or occasionally everybody would jump in.
I mean it was completely free form.
And because of that,
there was a lot of ball Boston.
Like when Bob Kelly's on the guy gets fucking tortured when Voss is on,
he gets tortured.
Yeah.
And because of that,
like getting tortured,
like everybody has to like mind their p's and q's and be on the ball.
You've got to cover all your bases.
It's the snake pit man.
Yeah.
Whereas if you do a lot of other radio shows,
even big shows,
it's one guest at a time.
Right.
You know,
and you don't,
you don't get tossed into like that sort of comedy cellar table sort of scenario
or you know,
the parking lot at the store or the bar at the Improv like this that
I always said when you,
when you went on ona and it was a packed room,
you know,
when you walked in and it was depaulo Bobby,
we're,
we're burned Patrice or whoever it,
when it was a packed room when ona,
I always said it was like getting dropped into the,
it was like in Raiders of the lost Ark when he hits the ground in that fucking
snake pit and it's just like,
you better like have your torch up and be ready because they are coming at you
from every fucking direction.
Yeah.
Snakes.
I hate snakes.
Yeah.
Asked very dangerous,
but it was also just fun.
You know,
it's like exciting to be in a room with Voss and Norton and everybody's like,
everyone's,
you know,
Norton say something fine,
they'll vasile say something funny.
And everybody's like chiming in and laughing and it's just,
it's so exciting.
It was,
it was those,
those times where the hardest times I've ever laughed in my life.
And I remember when I would have stints where I would quit drinking for awhile
and I,
I'd say like,
how the fuck am I going to have fun if I'm not going out drinking?
You know?
Uh,
I
would go,
oh,
that's right.
I laughed the hardest I ever did in my entire life at six 45 in the morning the
other day,
dead sober because I was on opie and Anthony.
Yeah,
yeah.
Watching Bobo Polish,
fucking pubes out or whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like literally crying,
laughing,
like to,
you couldn't breathe,
you know?
So it's like,
I was like,
okay,
it's possible.
It's possible to have sober,
fun,
obviously.
Well,
hanging out with comedians.
I mean,
that's the one thing me and Stan hope were talking once and he said I could quit
comedy but I can never quit hanging out with comics.
That's a great way to put it.
Yeah.
We were just laughing and fucking around May and we were just being ridiculous
and making each other Howell.
And uh,
we were just both shaking our head and he goes,
I could never stop hanging out with complex.
Uh,
it's great.
You know,
like he goes,
I don't fucking quit comedy.
I could quit comedy.
He just stopped performing.
Fuck it.
I can just fucking smoke cigarettes and drink beer and watch football.
You know,
like,
Hey,
I could do that.
He goes,
but I don't want to stop hanging out with comedians.
Cause it's like,
I think a guy like stand up also,
you get to a point where you realize,
I mean,
yeah,
it's fun to do shows and yeah,
it's,
but nothing's going to change.
You're not going to,
yeah.
Well,
and the best thing about hanging out with comics to me is like,
it's like the rings of Hell because there's hanging out with comedians.
Then there's hanging out with the comedians that are,
you know,
that are in,
that are the real comics,
not just general comedians that are the pro guys or whatever and girls.
Then it's the ring below that which is like,
these are the pros that are fucking cool,
you know,
that aren't egomaniacs.
Then there's the ring under that where it's like,
these are the pros that are ready to trash anything you want to talk about.
Everybody on the other three levels would scoff at what we're about to say,
but we'll go after anything down here on this,
on this little ring,
and it's the best.
It's the best,
you know?
Well,
this is an art form to saying fucked up shit that you don't even necessarily
really mean,
but especially when a bunch of comics are getting together and they're vibing
off of each other.
There's that thing that we do where you'll,
I'll try to say something like Tony the other day,
what the fuck did he say about Joan Rivers when Joan Rivers died?
Oh,
if you hurry up,
you could still get in bed with it.
I was supposed to do in bed with Joan.
It was like she was doing a podcast,
which she would do it from her bed.
Yeah.
And I was scheduled to do it and it got moved around and I was waiting to
reschedule it and then she died.
And it made me sad because,
uh,
I was a huge fan and Tony Hinchcliffe goes,
if you hurry up,
he could still get in bed with her.
It's not too late.
She probably hasn't started rotting yet.
Oh my God,
he didn't,
I don't think you said that,
but do,
I do,
but you can't say that in a normal company,
but amongst comedians,
you know,
it was to me,
made me feel good that he said that,
you know,
God,
you know what I'm saying?
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
Like Ari and I were talking
last night,
we went to canter's Deli late after is a thing,
we're,
we're driving home and he was talking about how he thinks it's good to interact
with regular people because he goes,
I don't talk to anybody that's a comedian and I think I'm not getting a balanced
perspective.
And he was like,
you know you do this sports commentary stuff where like you'll go a whole
weekend where you don't do stand up and you talk to like athletes and you talked
to like newspeople and stuff like that.
Like that's probably good for you.
And he goes,
cause I'm all I'm talking to is psychos.
Cool.
Also I could say something really fucked up and they're like ma'am,
right?
Yeah.
Like well yeah when we all right.
I feel like I learned this in therapy.
When somebody shares something with you,
you need to share back.
Oh so you know that we're like on the level together so I'm going to tell you a
fucked up thing.
But I was hanging out.
I don't even,
I feel bad cause David,
but I was hanging out with Pete Holmes.
He brought them in and it was right after,
it was right after a Robin Williams 11th it was right after Robin Williams thing
right after the Holocaust.
And they were saying,
they're saying it's an apparent suicide.
They found him with a belt around his neck and I was like,
pay.
Do you think he,
you think it was a suicide?
Do you think he was jacking it?
The belt around this deck and we just started laughing,
going apparent suicide always sounds way better in a newspaper.
Then definitely was jerking off with a belt around his neck.
Yeah.
Robin's case.
He cut his wrists too.
I know that part hadn't come out yet.
And uh,
you know,
I mean there's a,
there's a,
I have a human side.
I don't want to sell it.
It's true.
It's,
it's very sad to me that that happened and I respect that that happened.
And,
and if I was related to him,
I probably wouldn't want to hear a joke about it right now.
But,
but my point is,
is like,
you know,
sometimes you're hanging out with comics and you can let those little thoughts
out with them,
uh,
that I think a lot of people,
a lot of other calm,
if I was on nine out of 10 other podcasts right now,
I wouldn't have felt comfortable sharing that.
But see,
you shared the crazy Joan Rivers joke,
right?
And then I share that back and it's like,
it's like we're,
here we are,
we're in the fucking ninth ring together.
And Joan Rivers or Robin Williams I think would understand why those jokes were
funny.
I don't have the right to say this guy's name cause I wasn't there when it
happened,
but a very famous comedian came over to a table of comics at the,
uh,
at the seller and a right after Robin Williams died and went,
he was a joke thief,
right?
Fuck them really?
And walked away.
And everybody was like,
Oh shit.
Like looked at everybody went,
it was a joke thief.
Right?
Geez guys.
A joke thief.
Right.
And everybody like nod their head and he goes,
fuck them.
Walked away.
Yeah,
I don't,
I wasn't there.
So I don't know if it was funny.
The guy's fucking hilarious.
So I'm sure it was probably pretty funny when he said it,
but uh,
that's a real thing too with people.
That's a real
thing where some guys never want to let that shit go.
Um,
yeah,
no,
that's a very real thing.
I'm socially,
it was your bit like if you had a bit and all of a sudden it's on Letterman.
Look,
I'll tell Ya,
you know,
Mark's doing it.
There's something to be said for that.
Don't die with a grudge thing.
But I also do think it's bullshit a lot of the time,
you know,
I mean you watched that Ramones documentary into the century and they start
talking to g,
uh,
Johnny Ramone after Joey died and they go,
did you go visit him in the hospital?
He goes,
no.
And they go.
Even when he was dying,
you didn't go see him.
You knew he was going to die.
And he goes,
no,
if I was dying,
I wouldn't want him to come see me.
I don't like the guy.
We don't like each other.
And I was just like,
you know what,
man?
In certain ways I tip my hat to that.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
This is what it is,
man.
Like,
let's not,
let's not stroke ourselves here.
There's three levels.
There's levels,
like there's some people that you have fallen out with.
We could,
you could sort it out.
And there's some people you can't,
there's some people I don't want to be around cause I just don't want to feel
them.
I don't want to be in there.
I don't,
I think they're beyond my reach.
I agree on my hope.
Their perception of reality is so different than mine.
I don't,
I don't want to hate anybody,
but I don't want to communicate with them either.
Right.
Well,
you know,
like my mom taught me a great lesson about that sort of thing and she said the
opposite of hate isn't love.
The opposite of hate is in different.
Hmm.
When you truly don't care about somebody.
That's,
that's how's love for,
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry.
Let me,
let me,
I phrased it wrong.
The opposite of love isn't hate.
The opposite of love is indifference.
That's what it is.
Excuse me.
So where's hate fit in there?
Is it in the middle?
Hate means you still care.
Hate me.
And you still love the person.
It's not the opposite because if you hate,
if you hate,
you're invested.
You know?
And I mean,
I guess that investment doesn't necessarily Nessa necessitate love every time.
But hate is investment.
I'm spending my energy on you right now.
I'm wasting my energy on you.
You know,
you're my ex girlfriend.
You did me wrong.
It's two years later.
I can't pick up a mop without yelling the word content,
the ceiling,
because this is the fucking mop you bought when you lived here.
You know what I mean?
Like that's,
that's not the opposite of love.
That's you're still invested.
There's party.
You still in there somewhere that wishes everything was okay.
But indifference,
when you truly say,
I don't give a fuck if you live,
die,
breathe,
whatever,
like I'm done.
I have no nothing in me for you.
You know?
To me that is,
that's why they say what these fucking Twitter trolls.
You know,
I was arguing with people on Twitter for the last two days and people are going,
why are you going after him?
Don't,
don't show them that you care.
Don't show them.
And that's what that's,
yeah.
Yeah.
Why am I showing them that I care?
You know what I mean?
Like in differences.
What pisses off a Twitter troll?
Well,
sometimes it's fun.
I do.
I do think there's a gray area and um,
and that's the gray area was where I was trying to exist because I didn't like
what people were saying about,
yeah,
a friend of mine on there.
So I was trying to defend him.
I know what you're saying.
I mean,
there's times where it's worth your effort to communicate and there's times
where it's not,
it's a matter of how much emotionally you get invested in debating someone that
you don't even know.
I mean,
you,
you might meet them and they might be a fucking complete idiot.
There's no reason whatsoever to even communicate with them.
Like what's the point?
And getting all riled up and upset.
You're not even involved with that person.
You don't know that you choose to be involved with them because of 140
characters that are on a page.
You don't have to,
you don't have to,
you know.
Yeah.
There was a guy today that I stopped following that really came after me pretty
hard,
uh,
that I consider,
I wouldn't say a friend,
we didn't hang out,
but like,
we were friendly.
We were friendly.
Excuse me.
And,
um,
you know,
our,
our knowing of each other started in a weird way.
He was kind of like being a bit of a troll one day to me.
And I really went after him cause I was in a really bad mood.
And then I ended up meeting him at a party a year later and he came in,
he introduced himself and he was like,
hey man,
I was just joking.
I'm sorry that that got out of hand,
whatever you end up giving me a bag of weed,
you know,
he was really,
really cool.
And then we were cool.
And then like over these last two days,
he started tweeting me all this really fucking vicious shit about Andy kindler
and Andy's my friend.
And I was like,
dude,
I don't agree with you.
Stop saying that shit to me and stop putting my name in the fucking tweets like,
like you and me ride together and like,
and now my,
my friend is going to see his name getting smeared and my name's in the tweet
too and I'm just like,
dude,
you don't know what the fuck you talking about.
Stop.
And I was writing that back to him with both his and Andy's handling the tweets.
And he just kept doing it.
And I was just like,
you know what dude,
fuck it.
I'm not doing this.
And I wrote it.
I and other people chimed in,
we're saying the same dumb shit.
And I just wrote to everybody that I'm arguing with right now on Twitter,
please stop following me.
I can't stand any of the shit you're saying right now.
I'm serious.
Stop following me.
And they didn't.
And I was just like,
you know what?
Fuck it.
And I just unfollowed this dude.
I'm like,
what am I supposed to do?
Keep following a guy that's like waving his dick in my face.
You know what I mean?
It depends.
And you know,
and then he,
you know,
I wake up today at four 30 in the morning with anxiety from having a bad set of
the fucking charity Gig last night and I check my Twitter and there's like five
tweets at me from this guy.
You were never funny.
You're a piece of shit.
The shoe that has this guy,
uh,
I'll say his name is Fred from Brooklyn.
Is his Twitter handle at Fred from Brooklyn Comic?
I don't know what he does.
I think he has a podcast.
He's not like a guy anybody knows except like some,
he's part of that.
Don't put them up on the screen.
Yeah,
he's part of that ONA crew.
Um,
but like so just like was trying to hurt your feelings.
Yeah,
it was like,
it was,
it kind of made me sad to be honest because like he was doing it the way,
like a scorned lover does it.
Like,
like do two days ago you
were telling me you love me and now you're,
you're telling me I'm not funny.
It's like you're just,
you're just hurt.
Your feelings are hurt.
So it didn't upset me in that sense.
And by the way,
Fred,
if you're hearing this,
I'm not giving you attention because this got to me,
I'm just mature enough to talk about this and I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
I can't get into all the God damn head games of,
don't say his name.
That dude right now,
it's sweaty fingers.
You know?
It's just like,
and it's like,
and if you are listening to this,
it's like,
dude,
I'm not even mad at you.
It's like you were saying a bunch of Shit I didn't agree with.
And I was like,
all right dude,
I can't fuck with you anymore,
man.
And he's writing,
if you don't play Twitter by Derosa is rules,
he'll fucking,
he'll kill Blah on fall.
You,
he's a fucking cunt.
It's like,
dude,
weren't you one of the same guys that stood up for Anthony?
And we're pissed off that he came under fire for his words.
So you can attack other people when their words come under fire.
But I can't,
but nobody can criticize your work.
You know what I mean?
Like how the fuck does that coin?
Yeah,
that's it.
That's a real convenient fucking coin.
You're flipping their,
you know what I mean?
Um,
well why,
why worry about what his fucking hang up is?
Why spend so much energy on it?
That's the real issue.
Well,
now we're back to the thing about the indifference.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't,
it's not a lot of energy that I'm spending on it.
It's just,
I guess I'm just,
I don't remember why we got into Twitter,
but,
uh,
but oh,
you were saying the,
the,
you know these people from the hundred 40.
Yeah.
That's your only relationship to die.
You know,
you don't have to,
he was somebody that I actually genuinely liked,
like as a dude and troubled people.
Well,
that's why I say I wasn't mad.
It was more just like,
it was like,
I feel bad man.
Like I just feel bad for you,
dude.
Like you,
you're reacting the way,
like a dumped girl reacts right now.
You know what I mean?
You,
you know,
when someone says something like that to you,
it'll alleviates any responsibility you have for continuing to communicate with
them.
Like,
are you being a baby?
Okay.
Yeah.
And like if someone,
like some people will do that and they'll expect you to fire back at them and
they'll do it wanting you to fire back on it.
They want you to engage.
And that's where indifference comes in.
Like he,
but he,
this is an indifference necessarily cause we're kind of discussing it,
but you know,
it's,
it's important to recognize what you want to invest your energy yet.
Yes.
My hours in a day.
I agree.
I just don't like,
like part,
I will say this,
my only emotional investment in that back and forth and like sending out a tweet
that says,
please stop following me to anybody that feels this way.
I want people like that out of my life.
I don't want them coming to my shows.
I don't want them around.
I don't,
and,
and it's not because they'd said mean things about Andy Kindler I can deal with
somebody saying mean things about Andy Kindler it's the reasons they were saying
the mean about Andy Kindler
they're pissed off because Andy Kindler,
uh,
address the Anthony situation at Montreal and now it's,
we see blood and we and attack and kill and it's fucking stupid.
It's mob mentality.
I don't agree with it.
I don't want people like that behind me in any way,
in any fucking way.
Well,
you know,
Andy Kindler is a very progressive guy,
very smart guy.
And uh,
he,
you know,
if he met Anthony and he had a conversation with them,
maybe they would have a difference of opinion.
Maybe they would argue,
I don't know.
But I respect them both.
Yeah.
It's a tricky,
tricky situation where Anthony Kumina situation for folks who don't know Anthony
from opie and Anthony was fired because,
um,
he was in a situation,
another situation,
line situation.
I can't stop saying situation.
It's stuck in my head.
He was taking photographs late at night and Times Square.
Some woman,
he took her photograph and she got mad at him.
She hit him yelling at him,
screaming at him,
and then he went on this rant about the African American community,
about violence,
about all sorts of different things and he got fired for the rent.
And uh,
you know,
if anybody pays any attention to him on the opiate Anthony Show,
they know that he does that all the time.
That that style of communication is his thing.
But you can explain yourself way better on a radio show when you going back and
forth with people and you cite statistics and facts about the African American
community,
there's no doubt about it.
I mean,
there's no way to deny it.
There's a disparity in the amount of African American people that are in prison.
There's a disparity in the amount of African American people that commit crime,
but that could be attributed to a bunch of different things,
economic factors,
the,
there,
the opportunities that they have as opposed to the opportunities that people
that live in better neighborhoods have it.
There's a lot of shit going on there.
It's a complex,
nuanced discussion and you're not going to have a complex,
nuanced discussion.
I have to get punched in the face.
It's going to start screaming and yelling and he should have just stayed off the
air or stayed offline.
We should have done is talked about it on the radio show on Monday morning and
expressed the whole story.
It's a sensitive issue.
Very sensitive.
And I think that,
you know,
I,
I'll be honest with you,
this is the first time I've ever talked about this publicly to anybody.
Uh,
and when this all happened,
I got a lot of shit online about not coming out and saying Stan with ant or
defendant or whatever.
Um,
because I wanted to see the situation through before I said anything and I
don't,
I didn't agree with the initial outburst on Twitter,
but I thought to myself,
okay,
he was angry.
It was fucked up.
Let his blood fucking calm.
Maybe he'll apologize or reword things or whatever.
Uh,
also too,
I think if you're going to be somebody that complains about the problems in a
community,
you need to come,
you need to address those problems and try to help offer solutions,
not just yell from a hilltop about how fucked up it is and how you're pissed off
about it.
I don't think that helps anything.
And that's that kind of addressing of a problem is what makes people start
saying,
what's,
what's going on with this guy?
You know what I mean?
It,
it starts to sound like a very one sided attack on something.
Now you can agree or anybody could agree or disagree with that point and we can
even move beyond that point to this point,
which is after he went on that app had that Twitter outbursts.
So I was like,
okay,
that was unfortunate,
but let's see what he says now.
Then he went on red eye and was like,
I'm not sorry.
I'm not apologizing.
I am not sorry for what I did.
And I was like,
okay,
this is starting to get a little bit more complicated now.
And then after that,
I mean by the time he went on that like white nationalists radio show to like
defend himself.
I was just like,
I,
I don't know where this,
I didn't hear that.
Well,
I saw it online,
uh,
transcript or did you hear it?
There was a part,
there was part of a transcript of some stuff he said.
Uh,
but I found online cause I was just kind of following the situation that he had
gone on basically a white nationalist podcast or radio show or something.
Uh,
and it's like the guy,
the host of the show is on Wikipedia.
He's got a Wikipedia page and it was like the Wikipedia page.
It was like,
this is a guy that has had like Holocaust deniers and shit on a show.
Like your friend from Ireland.
He wasn't my friend who was my neighbor and I didn't know he thought that until
it came out that night.
And they choose exaggerated made lad.
Oh,
he's have to meet rocky times.
By the way,
if that guy had a radio show,
I wouldn't have gone on it.
So when I saw that,
I mean you can,
you guys look it up so you like it doesn't know something I don't want,
I don't want to publicize and he fucking white nationalists.
Fair.
Know what I mean?
So,
so,
um,
anyway,
so when I saw that I was like,
and saw some of Anthony's quotes from the show,
I was like,
this is,
this is getting fucked up.
So do you think he just went off the deep end because he was angry and he was
trying to publicize the whole situation?
Or do you think he's really racist?
Like what's your take on it?
It will probably as good as I know him when it first happened and I'm going to,
I'm putting this disclaimer out before I say anything.
Uh,
I am fully aware of the hell fire that I might face for not just saying I'm with
the guy on this stuff.
I'm fully aware of it.
Um,
I've thought about this very long and very hard.
I am aware of it.
Um,
I'm not,
you know that I'm just saying that anyway,
uh,
the,
Eh,
when it first happened I was like,
this is really fucking unfortunate and I want to believe that my friend fucked
up and I want to believe that my friend is,
is going to redeem himself from this.
And the further it went down the road and finally for,
for me,
the last final Straw was the shitty was tweeting about the Ferguson situation.
I was just like,
I can't,
I unfollowed him on Twitter.
I was like,
I can't do this man.
And that's not me saying fuck you.
Comea that's me saying,
look dude,
you have the,
he has the absolute right to say whatever he wants to say.
I would never ever,
ever say somebody doesn't have the right to speak out loud about what they say,
but I also have the right to react to it.
And I also have the right to say if that's how you feel about this shit.
I disagree so strongly and this is such a,
this is such a,
to me,
an ethical and moral issue when it comes,
when you start dealing with race.
I don't know how we can pal around still,
you know what I mean?
Because this is,
this is,
this is beyond like political differences to me.
You know,
it's like once it starts getting into racial stuff and I have to start thinking
about what does it say to my black friends if I still hang out,
you know,
uh,
with a certain person,
I,
you know,
it's,
it's a real fucking tight spot.
At that point they also didn't agree with.
I also didn't agree with the whole thing where everybody was really on this like
cancel your subscriptions thing and what and Fuck opion Jim over.
Fuck them out of a job.
Let Sirius Xm lose all this business.
I mean,
those guys were,
were were left in a in a really tough situation and they're making the best out
of it.
And for everybody to,
that was behind Anthony to go,
yeah,
canceling your fucking subscription.
Why?
Well now why are you fucking these people over?
What did they do?
They didn't do anything and it just was such a messy thing.
It was just such a messy thing.
And everybody was saying,
this is a free speech issue.
It's not a free speech issue.
Speech is free.
Freedom of speech is,
it's free,
but it doesn't mean it comes without consequences.
It works like a giant candy dish at your doctor's office.
It's there for the taking,
but if you don't handle it carefully or or,
or,
or use with any responsibility,
you're going to get sick and fuck yourself up a little bit.
You gotta be careful.
There are repercussions for free speech,
free speech.
Just means you're allowed to say it.
It doesn't mean nothing bad can happen afterwards,
you know?
And so when people were,
were talking about like,
I can't believe that they fired him,
it's like,
well,
whether you agree with him getting fired or not,
you can't believe that they fired him.
If you had a pizza shop and one of your top pizza makers was across the street
saying that stuff and your customers could hear him,
you'd be like,
we hate this fucking guy away from the pizza shop right now.
This is bad for pizza business.
So I don't see how Sirius Xm is any different.
Now again,
whether you agree with him getting fired or not is a different story.
But to say we can't understand why he got fired.
I just think it's such a closed minded one way sa one side and way of looking at
it.
I think this was approached with zero gray area and um,
on
one hand I kind of appreciate their loyalty now that they want to stick up for
Anthony and they want to do that.
But there,
there are real issues when you start discussing race that you have to take any
consideration.
And like this Ferguson thing,
you know,
the Ferguson thing is a very unique situation because it's an incredibly
impoverished community with a lot of fucking crime,
a lot of crime,
and a lot of police brutality,
right?
Like it does to just an awful place.
It's awful.
And um,
it,
it's not as simple as black people or white people.
I,
this is gonna sound stupid,
but I wished it was no race and wish there was no color.
I wish it was no differentiation other than your behavior.
Because if that was the case,
we would be able to look at behavior and we did to be,
look at all of these people that are involved in tremendous amounts of crime.
Okay.
What are the variables there were,
where,
what are the single parent households?
What are the absentee parents?
What are the kids that are growing up with drug addicts?
What are the kids that are growing up with crime in their environment
constantly.
That that's what's going on.
It's not just black people.
Why I don't fucking crazy white people.
I grew up with a lot of poor white people that were insane.
They're just as God damn dangerous is anybody.
Well,
there's nobody that's less dangerous when it comes to poverty and crime.
You know?
It's like you get poverty and crime and bad scenarios and then children
potential that's growing up in this really distorted and fucked up way.
You're going to get crazy.
People should go to the grow up with crime,
commit crime.
People imitate their atmosphere.
People who grow up in terrible environments,
it's very difficult to rise above and you can't just,
you can't just say it's a black thing or a white thing and it just,
because it's in the black community more that's in the white community.
Look,
man,
you got to take into consideration that have hundred and fucking 50 years ago
there was slavery.
Okay.
And the great grandchildren of those slaves or the what,
what you're dealing with today.
And that's,
that's a real,
and I'm not a fan of reparations or any of that,
those ideas that a lot of people bantered back and forth,
but I am a fan of what I would call social or civil engineering.
Social engineering is probably not a bad idea to try to rejuvenate impoverished
communities that are predominantly one race.
I mean it seems to me that those places are a trap and if you're born in those
places,
whether it's poor white,
Irish people that are fucking criminals and meth heads or whether it's black
people that you grow up and your parents,
both your parents are in jail.
He'd been raised by grandmother who sells crack.
That's a terrible,
and there's,
these are terrible environment to get people coming out of and they're very
commonplace.
Yeah,
that's the real issue.
The real issue is children that grow up in these environments and become really
fucked up members of society.
It has nothing to do with race.
Just so happens that a lot of them are black.
I agree.
And that's why,
that's why I think when statements start becoming things like that,
community is so quick to jump to violence and savages and statements like that.
It's in one hand he's right.
On one hand,
he's right statistically,
but the real question is why are those communities more likely and is it because
they've been ignored?
You know,
are as a society,
we have a right,
we have rather an obligation to,
to take care of our community,
right?
But how far does our community extent,
that's where it gets really problematic because our community,
when we think about America as a community,
it's 350 million people that stretches out thousands of miles.
It's impossible to get everybody on board,
right?
It's simple.
If we add a community and our community was 20 people and there was one guy who
had no fucking money and who was doing a terrible job raising his kids and he
was on drugs all the time and he,
his kids were left along,
we would take that kid in,
right?
We would all take that kid in,
We all would,
but we can't.
When there's a million kids like that.
And then those kids grew up and they become adults and they were,
they were ignored and there's no love and there's a just,
just as disastrous circumstance that they're growing up.
And that's what's wrong.
I don't believe that it's a color issue.
I believe it's an environmental issue.
I think it's a genetic issue in that the,
the genetics of the people that were in these fucked up environments,
they're raising more people that are in these fucked up environments.
It's epigenetics,
learning from your environment that passes on to the next generation.
But it's not a race thing.
It's just an environmental thing.
It could be white people that are in poor neighborhoods like those Gypsies in
England.
Those are people are God damn savages.
Those people that are driving around those caravans,
having bare knuckle fights with each other,
robbing everybody left and right.
I have a friend who,
they're,
um,
they're good friends in England.
They're from England and they have good friends in England that had to abandon
their home cause Gypsies moved into a park next to their house and when they
have like these weird laws over there,
when these gypsies shell up and under,
not all bad I'm sure,
but these particular Gypsies that moved next to them were bad.
They started robbing the neighborhood.
We started leaving their garbage everywhere.
They would dig holes and shit and them,
they was just chaos.
They would have,
they would stay up late at night and drinking and screaming and fighting and it
was just,
and they couldn't get rid of him.
There's nothing they could do about them.
Had nothing to do with race.
It had everything to do with who are these fucking human beings.
There were white people,
there were white people that were completely fucking out of control.
Right.
But if you took those same white people,
raised them in a nice neighborhood,
you up,
raised him in studio city,
put them in a nice suit and have them a walk into their BMW.
No one blinked an eye the same human being.
Right,
right.
No.
Yeah,
I hear you.
I totally agree.
I can I go back to something you said earlier
when you said on the one hand you admire their
loyalty for [inaudible],
for going with him.
I think it's shortsighted,
but here's my thing.
As far as I understood it was about that show,
you know,
I mean the fan base,
I mean was about that show and about what that shows stood for and to me,
nothing about saying fuck you to two other guys and we're,
we're gonna f 100% gonna follow one guy was anything that that shows stood for,
it showed zero unity to me.
It just didn't,
it just didn't it to to to throw two other dudes under a bus and go and have no
consideration for the situation that they're left in.
You know?
I understand.
If you want to have consideration for the position,
Anthony's in not saying they shouldn't have had consideration,
I'm saying,
but to have zero consideration for the other two and go fuck it.
We're out of here.
Cancel subscription.
Well,
that's the thing I didn't agree with that just felt like it felt like mob
mentality to me.
I see what you're saying,
what you're saying,
but in their defense,
I think what they were trying to do was there's only one way to force their hand
and the w the way wasn't sit back the way it was.
The cancel subscriptions deal serious brought Anthony back as they wanted to
show as a whole,
so their idea wasn't the fuck Jimmy and oop.
Their idea was to cancel serious because it would force their hand and make them
bring back.
Can't prove a point.
Yeah.
That was the only thing that they could do.
I mean if you wanted to bring back Anthony,
there was really no other way to act,
but I never felt,
now look,
I might be wrong.
How else could they have acted?
Just,
hey guys,
this is,
this is fucking unfortunate animal listens to that and we'll to economics.
We'll listen to,
we'll also subscribe to this thing over here now.
Do you know what I mean?
Because now I might be wrong about this,
but as far as I could see it was never painted in the light of,
of we're leaving and we'll be back if you rehire him.
It was fuck him.
We're done.
That two days later Anthony was like,
I'm starting my own show.
It was,
and then for a week,
two weeks,
those subscription cancellations were coming in.
So it never to me once came across as we're doing this now as a walkout,
as a strike.
And if you guys do what we think is the right thing,
we'll bring him back.
It struck me very immediately as like he's out the door,
he's starting his own thing.
These people are continually jumping ship and I just think that kind of sucks
for the other two guys.
And I'm,
I realize I'm not speaking for them right now.
I don't know how they feel about it.
Um,
and I don't mean to talk out of turn.
No,
I know,
I know what you're saying,
but I see what you're saying.
But I think for them I can totally understand why they wanted a boycott.
Cause I think for them that was the only way to voice their opinion in a way
with a company be forced to listen if the company had 50,000 people cancer,
this subscriptions because Anthony [inaudible] got fired.
And then everybody said,
oh we shit,
we just lost x amount of revenue.
Um,
can we get Anthony to apologize and bring them back?
Boom,
he's back on the show.
Right.
And he wouldn't have apologized though.
Well,
um,
no,
but I think there could have been a way to,
I don't think an apology it was as necessary or as an explanation and an a
discussion.
You know,
I think if they had a discussion of the issue on Monday,
he could have said the exact same things that he said in those tweets,
but said them.
And it's very different to hear someone say something,
talk about being punched in the face by someone in the African American
community.
See,
but look,
I got to take another position too,
because I don't think you should have been taken a picture of that check without
her permission.
I don't think it's cool to be,
you're a woman.
And this guy.
I'm not a white knight here.
Okay,
but hear me out if you're a woman and some fucking dude on the street is
pointing a camera at you and taking pictures.
That shit's creepy.
And maybe dudes don't think that way because they think they're innocent.
They're just capturing.
They would prefer to be anonymous.
I'm just capturing the city.
I just love taking photographs.
I think it's a beautiful city.
It's interesting.
It's fascinating.
I like taking pictures of cabs.
I don't get their permission.
This is a person there just happened to be walking down the street.
I'm going to take a picture of him.
I disagree with that.
I think especially in the case of a man taking a photograph of a woman,
men are traditionally the pursuers.
I mean that's we,
we're,
we're liars.
If we pretended that there's anything other than that going on.
Yeah.
Women pursue sometimes,
but most creepers are dudes.
Right.
And when a dude is taking photographs,
if I was a chick out,
immediately assumed that he,
that he was a creeper.
So,
in my opinion,
this woman,
it was,
it was probably,
I don't know what the fuck was said.
Si.
So I mean I'm even commenting at of school.
Well that's the tough part is it becomes like the Watergate tapes,
there's like this missing 20 minutes.
She was missing all minutes.
We all have any time.
Zero words.
Exactly.
So I mean it's,
it's,
it literally goes from,
I was taking a picture too,
I got hit in the face and called white motherfucker.
This is how I felt like this about the Zimmerman case too.
You know,
everybody was like,
Oh,
you know,
this is a clear cut case.
Like I was a piece of shit and you know,
George Zimmerman's an awful person and that kid,
you know,
he should have been,
or then there's other people that said that kid was a punk.
He was beating him up.
He should have shot him.
Right.
My take was always like,
what would have happened if someone who was cooler and they talked to that kid,
what would have happened with someone who understands people better?
What would it mean?
What if the whole scenario it played out where it was a dude who's really good
at communicating with people and very respectful and said to the kid,
how you doing today?
My brother,
everything good?
And the kid said,
everything's good man.
You know what,
what are you up to?
You know?
I mean,
who knows?
Maybe the kids say just head back from the store man.
Alright,
stay dry.
And who knows?
You know what I'm saying?
Exactly.
A fucking Dork like George Zimmerman might've caused that altercation just by
being a social fuckhead.
Well I think if,
yeah,
I mean I thought I,
I certainly thought so.
I went,
I was open minded to the point of going,
I understand if that the guy had his suspicions raised or whatever,
but then when you listen to those cell phone calls and he's like chasing the guy
around the neighbor,
it was so painfully
obvious to me that here's a guy that just wants to be a hero.
Here's a wanna be cop that wants to be a hero and shit got out of hand.
He bit off more than he could chew.
He got his fucking ass kicked by a kid and he ended up killing somebody over it,
you know,
and like somehow slid through that self defense loophole because uh,
seven,
how old was Trayvon's?
16 got on top of him and it was beating his ass.
Yeah,
it was beating his ass.
But you know,
look,
the,
it's like the Ferguson thing.
Those two,
all anybody was talking about was the first was,
was the,
was the video of the guy,
the defenders of the cop.
All they were talking about was the guy,
you know,
shoving the guy in the convenience store and stealing the cigar,
whatever it was.
Two white witnesses came out yesterday finally and said,
we saw the shooting and his hands were up.
His hands were up when he was shot,
you know,
so now,
regardless of this weird phantom gunfire shot that happened when the cop was in
the car,
whatever weird fucking altercation thing happened there,
whether it was that dude's fault or the cup,
whatever,
regardless of any of that,
the guys getting chased,
the cop is chasing him.
If he's got his fucking hands up.
You're a cop dude at that point.
That's it.
You don't shoot,
you don't shoot a dude to death,
you just don't,
well the guy who was the cop that shot him was also a guy that was a part of
another band of cops that was so fucked up.
It's so many complaints about them that they disbanded the whole department and
then he got hired by Ferguson.
Yeah,
it's,
he had a history of that kind of abuse.
Yeah.
And you know,
it's so,
you know,
to,
unless you don't want to talk about this anymore,
but like,
you know,
again,
with the Kumi a thing,
you know,
look at at the end of the day with Anthony and this is what,
why when I saw the Ferguson tweets I was like,
oh that's it.
I can't,
you know,
cause when you see him he would,
I don't want to get into what he was tweeting,
but like the point is,
is that I didn't,
I harshly
agree with it.
Well,
I think he's a bit like,
you know,
I mean,
I don't want to cast him in a bad light because he's my friend.
But I think he's a bit like your friend that's a spurned lover.
I mean,
I think there's a little bit of that,
of that he's fired by this company's like,
yeah,
fuck you.
I'm going to go even deeper with it now.
I'm getting even more crazy with it now.
Don't give a fuck.
No.
Yeah,
no,
he is.
And it's,
it's,
I got to say,
man,
like at the end of the day,
um,
the whole thing just makes me sad.
And I know at probably deepened as Corp Anthony doesn't really give a fuck about
what I think we were friends.
Uh,
and you know,
like we used to hang out.
I was bummed out,
man.
I was bummed out that I felt like I got to a point with a friend where I was
like,
I don't think I can hang out with this guy anymore.
And it really bummed me out.
But did you talk to him in person?
I texted him twice.
He,
he didn't respond to the first one.
The second one,
he responded to me.
Uh,
the second text I sent,
I was a little pissed honestly that I didn't get a response from the first one.
And then I texted him a second time,
like two weeks later and I said,
hey man,
I don't know if you've got my other text.
But uh,
the first text was just like,
hey man,
you know,
I know you're going through some shit right now.
I'm sorry that you're in a tough position and I just want you to know I had
great times in the,
in the studio with you and I wish you well man.
Like I felt like I could say that much to a guy,
even though I didn't agree with the shit that came out of his mouth,
I could say that much to him.
I owe a lot of my career to opie and Anthony and Jimmy.
So that was the first text.
I didn't hear back from him and I was like,
okay,
fine.
And then two weeks later I texted him again and he said,
hey man,
I don't know if he got my other texts,
but there's some guy online writing fake retweets of me saying really nasty shit
about you.
I go,
I'm not that,
those aren't my tweets.
That's not me.
And then he responded to that one.
He was like,
hey man,
I was new.
We were cool.
Don't worry about it,
Duh Duh,
Duh.
And I was like,
oh cool man.
Like you know,
let's have a beer at some point because in my head I was like,
this was still before the redeye icon or at least I saw the red I clip and
stuff.
And I was still thinking like this will turn around,
this will turn around.
That's what I just kept thinking.
And after that I started seeing all the other stuff and that's when I started to
be like,
Whoa,
well we'll,
and I'll be honest,
man.
Like what really bummed me out one day was was he like Kinda,
he knew I was getting a lot of shit online cause his name was in the tweets
and he never wants told these people to leave me the fuck alone.
But don't you think that he was,
first of all,
this was a national story.
Okay,
this is a huge story.
Don't you think that he was probably completely overwhelmed and may very well
have been ignoring his app replies because there was overwhelming.
He said Nice things about burr.
He said Nice things about Bobby Kelly.
He said,
Nice.
There's other comics.
I don't remember the nice things about me.
So nice things about you ignored you.
Uh,
well it doesn't.
Yeah.
It wasn't like I'm not important enough.
I'm not important enough.
Seriously.
Don't you think that's it?
Or is it just like,
here's why I think that's what it is.
Here's why I think that's what it is.
Because not only did he not
help get some of the fucking heat off of me and there was a lot of it.
Um,
when he finally did address me on Twitter as people like Colin Quinn and,
um,
who's the guy from the vice guy?
What's his name?
Uh,
which vice guy that a god damn.
Shane.
Shane Smith.
Not Shane.
The,
the guy that left vice with the beard.
Oh,
the guy who got in trouble recently for a talking about transsexuals.
Probably Gavin's yeah.
Yeah.
Gavin.
Collin Quinn.
We're getting tweets like,
hey,
would you please come do my new show?
I'll send a car
for you.
Hahaha.
Dm me.
Come to my show please.
My tweet in the midst.
By the way,
by the way,
Anthony bleeding them.
Yes.
Spurned lover.
Now you feel that?
No,
I'm just,
I'm just gonna say Burn Lover Talk Today.
By the way,
by the way.
Uh,
some of my,
uh,
I guess anger about the situation is when you're sitting at your aunt's funeral
who was like a second mother to you and your phone keeps buzzing cause you're
getting tweets like you're a talentless shit.
Selfish shit bag cunt.
Stick up for cu mia.
Okay.
You need to take that fucking at replies,
right?
Fucking notifications.
You don't have your phone buzzed when people tweet you write what are you an
amateur?
But maybe,
but my point is is like there was some,
there was some personal stuff in there because I was like,
I was like,
I'm getting shit for not disguising.
Give a fuck about me.
Obviously.
Like he's the one ever he wants,
why am I being held overwhelmed man?
So you kind of talked to a guy before you form an opinion in my opinion.
Well this was the tweet I got.
This was the tweet I got.
Okay.
Hey fuck head from you,
from,
from Anthony.
Hey fuck head.
Are you going to do my show when you're in New York?
That's the tweet I got when he knew there was bullshit going on online.
Then he calls me out in front of everybody like,
you're on the spot,
Douche,
let's go dance.
Are you coming on or not?
And I responded,
you know,
I'm 10% black.
Right?
Cause I thought that was fucking funny and nothing.
Nothing.
Okay.
Not a favorite,
not a reply.
Nothing.
Very personal action of air it out in this manner.
Why you got all worked up?
I've not worked on it.
This is all just an interpersonal situation.
We were talking about like a more complex issue of racism and you know what he
said?
Nah.
And then it became all about him not being nice to you.
No.
No I don't.
No,
no,
no.
It seems like you're taking Twitter.
I've way too seriously.
Awesome.
I've,
I mean when,
whenever I have a problem with Twitter,
I either banned user ignore it or anything like that.
But it seems like you'd take your very,
uh,
are,
do you and your personal life before Twitter and everything,
do you,
do you get in a lot of confrontations with people?
No.
No,
I don't.
I used to,
I don't a lot in my personal life.
I like.
I used to,
I used to be bad about confrontation.
but the only reason I'm bringing in any personal stuff is because you were
asking me when I said he doesn't give a fuck about me.
You know like the guy man,
you got to talk to him sometimes.
You know sometimes the people are busy man and when when he said fuck face or
whatever,
he says like hey fuck face.
Are you going to do my show or whatever.
He said,
do you think maybe he was just like,
hey fuck face.
Wouldn't you give myself,
it sounds like a text I might get from Brian.
Yeah.
Cause it seems like you and your head,
we're reading it like hey fuck face.
You were all worked up.
I mean let's build it up.
You were all worked up,
your aunt died,
you're at the funeral,
you're phone's busy buzzing.
People calling.
It still doesn't change the fact that I wouldn't do the show.
I mean because you because of that.
No,
because of the stuffies.
Yeah,
but didn't you?
I would do it even though I don't agree with what he said because he's my friend
and if we disagreed I'd love to,
I'd like to disagree with them on air.
Like you know,
people that I'm friends with have opinions I don't agree with and sometimes I've
had opinions that are off base and someone is sort of explained things to me in
a way that's made me think about things in a different way.
I don't,
I don't know if Anthony is capable of being reached like that,
but you know sometimes you can buy always someone in say something that opens
their eyes.
I always,
in the beginning of this whole situation,
I absolutely thought that he was and I have lost the hope of that and I feel
like at this point for me to act like it,
it's like I'm like,
see,
I feel like if I say this,
it sounds like I'm judging you and I don't mean to be judging you right now.
Like,
but I feel like if I were to go on his show,
it would make,
it would,
unless it was under the guise of Joe come on and we'll debate race.
And it's like,
okay,
then I could go on and hey,
it doesn't matter what this guy thinks I am allowed to do this.
But if I went on the show and let's say we didn't get around to debating race,
now I'm sitting and we're just laughing and Yucky.
To me that looks like I'm giving a stamp of approval,
you know,
and I,
I can't,
it's like,
you know,
it's okay.
I could,
I could understand your opinion.
I mean,
um,
my a friendship with him is,
uh,
it's pretty deep.
I really enjoyed doing that show and I have a lot of respect for him and I
probably don't agree with them.
A lot of issues when it comes to race,
especially because,
because I've,
I have these opinions about things being much,
much more complicated than simply black people do this.
White people do that.
I don't think it's that,
I think it's poverty.
It's an economic,
it's a cultural issue.
It's an issue with people get stuck.
They are stuck in bad neighborhoods,
they're stuck in economic situations.
And I think we probably both agree with that.
Yeah.
And Anthony,
um,
has some very good points about the reality of statistics in these communities.
I think it's a much more complex issue,
but sure.
His,
his,
um,
issue is that people want to deny those realistic statistics.
Sure.
Reality of those statistics is undeniable in my opinion.
I just think that there's more to it than simply the statistics.
Sure.
And I think that society as a whole has done a really shitty job at taking care
of the lowest social and economic rung of the ladder.
I think people have ignored it because it's convenient cause they don't have to
do anything about it.
Yeah.
Uh,
but you know,
a lot of people accuse you of socialism if you say things like that.
I've had,
I had someone call me a socialist today because of that.
I'm like,
you know,
look,
if you think taking care of poor babies is socialism.
Yeah,
I'm a socialist.
But yeah.
Well,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
it's just like they didn't fucking ask to be born again.
Oh Man.
And if you,
you can't feel that,
you know,
you don't,
you don't have any remorse or you know,
any compassion for people that are born in terrible situations.
To me that's a,
that's a mark against you as a human being.
I agree with that.
I totally agree with that.
Which is why,
so why wouldn't you just have a discussion with him about it?
Like to try to figure out
how do you have a discussion with a guy that doesn't return your texts?
Okay.
Board doesn't get back to you,
but if he did,
would you still,
you know what I'm saying?
Like if he did,
would you have that conversation because you,
you just said that you thought it would give him a stamp of approval.
No,
no,
no.
That's not,
no,
that's not what I said.
What I said was,
I said I would go on,
I would absolutely go on his show if debate this was to discuss race.
I wouldn't go on the show if that wasn't preset that we were going to do that
because if we didn't get around to discussing race,
then we're just having a good time.
You know what I mean?
And it's,
it's just not cool to me.
But you know,
I just PR look,
now here's the thing,
here's the thing.
And again,
I,
I want us to,
well let me just say this to defend myself a little bit.
I am not sore about the way he treated me.
I'm not upset.
Say butthurt.
Yeah,
I'm not butthurt thank you.
I'm not my,
my ass.
My little ass.
He Poo doesn't hurt.
Um,
and I'm not trying to,
and I'm in no way trying to air a grievance,
a personal grievance right now on your show about this in any fucking way.
I only went into that stuff cause you were saying when I started talking about
it,
I don't think he really cares what I think.
Um,
I had,
I had a friendship with a guy.
Um,
you know,
when I reached out and tried to get to a deeper place with him about this and
discuss,
maybe have a discussion or whatever about this,
let's grab a beer by,
let's grab a beer.
Never received a response.
You know,
I didn't get it.
Let's stop right here.
But you know,
all that really is very personal.
This is,
you know what I mean?
This is not about the issue itself.
This is what you and him and your relationship and I don't know what the fuck it
is,
but I think what they should have done from the beginning is say we're going to
ride our contract out when that pitch is over.
We're going to go on the Internet.
Do the opiod Anthony show when our contract is out.
I mean,
I don't even know if they can say that,
but their contracts out in like October,
they might already be doing planning.
I hope they are.
Because I think that the reality of satellite radio is it's awesome because it's
in your car.
It's way better than terrestrial radio.
You've got Howard Stern,
you got opie and Anthony,
you got all these radio stations that have,
you know,
have great music on them.
Find channels you can find.
You know,
I love classic vinyl.
It's great.
I love listening to satellite radio,
but you have to listen to what they want you to listen to.
I don't listen to it.
I have it in my car most of the time.
I listen to podcasts,
right?
Most of the time I'm listening to hardcore history or radio lab or you know,
any of our friends podcast.
That's what I do most of the time.
I don't,
I just think it's an archaic way.
Do you get programming?
It's this idea that you have to listen to what's on when it's on it.
That's great.
If you happen to be flipping through the channels or you turn on your car and
Opie and Anthony comes on,
or the Anthony and Jimmy show,
whatever they call it now,
or opion Jimmy when it comes on and it's an interesting interview,
it's great,
but sometimes you just want to listen to what you want to listen to.
Sure.
It'd be great if I could say,
oh look,
Joe Derosa is on Joey Diaz,
his podcast.
Let me just press play on that and I have like a whole like,
or I could go listen to Arnold Schwarzenegger on the Nerdist or this and that or
you know,
whatever.
Sure.
That I think is the future and I think that's the present also and I think that
once that's readily available in all cars at all times,
the idea of them working for satellite radio be sound kind of silly.
Like why would you choose to have a boss when?
What is the difference between the distribution method of satellite radio and
the Internet?
That's how you,
what the differences there is a difference.
Satellite radio is more restrictive,
warm,
strict,
just more advertising.
You don't get as much of a piece of it and you've got this massive overhead
because you're attached to this gigantic company that's totally unnecessary and
you can get fired.
Apparently you can get fired for talking you,
you have to rent this giant fucking building.
You mean there's a fucking floor.
You have to show id,
go through the whatever.
Florida is the way the fuck up there,
because there's all this money that's being spent where look at this fucking
place.
This reaches the same amount of people or more really,
this show reaches more most satellite radio shows and we do it from a fucking
office park.
It's a joke that the future is,
the distribution method is changing and the distribution method,
I think it's being tested by these sort of situations where you find out that
you could be fired for something totally unrelated to this show.
Right.
It's not like they went on the show and he said something that the company
can't,
like he went on the show and said something totally racist and the company's
like,
you can't say that on our show.
You're fired.
No,
he said it on his own Twitter.
You know it the very least,
they should have had some form of a debate with the guy,
but I think there's more to it than that.
And I think when you talk about this a white nationalist radio station that he
went on,
I think there's a little bit of that there too.
Like they might've been more to behind the scenes.
Well but,
and this is,
and I'm no way retreading or trying to beat a dead horse here,
but this is why I'm saying I'm not trying to be personal.
I agree with everything you're saying but I'm saying how I feel like I almost
felt like he wasn't that open to having the discussion.
Maybe it wasn't.
So it's like how can you,
on the one hand everybody,
and this is,
which drives me nuts about like this sort of blind like,
like I know what's going to happen.
I'm going to leave here.
I'm going to get a flood of tweets tonight.
Why?
You know why you're going to cause I'm saying care.
Well no I don't freaking out cause they know they can make your phone buzz.
I don't,
I go,
I'm going to shut that part off that off already.
How much has it gone off?
All the shows on like crazy.
I got to,
I got a confession to make.
I lied.
I don't have my Twitter alerts on my phone.
I went outside during the funeral to get some air and I checked my Twitter and
then I saw the stuff
Jerry.
But I was
trying to just get through the God who was the last story I used to be on your
phone.
Oh,
it was just I the years.
That's a big y.
Yeah,
it was a big line.
I glad you owned up to that.
Um,
but that's,
and it doesn't,
I mean I guess yeah,
to,
to certain extent.
It does bother me that I'll get some of these sweets whenever.
But that to me is what bothers me about the whole discussion is because I feel
like everybody's going,
it should have been more open minded.
It should have been more open minded.
It's like,
okay,
well I can speak from the place of somebody that was trying to approach it more
open minded.
And I felt like I didn't,
there wasn't an option to do that.
I felt like that wasn't there so well,
it's just because of your relationship with Anthony.
Well,
I mean,
well,
no,
I also mean like just in the public discussion forums,
like the second you don't,
you didn't,
not you,
but any general,
the second you didn't Hashtag stand with ant or come out and say something.
You were a trader and a piece of shit and it's like,
well that's not open minded discussion either.
Talking about the pests.
Wait,
why are you looking for open mind discussion?
People are savages.
Yeah,
they are.
They are.
I don't know.
I guess I always think that because,
because like the,
the,
the shit heels or more prone to write stuff,
more voice.
The negative opinion than the positive people are new to voice.
The positive.
It seems like the majority voice is that sort of negative voice.
Sometimes they're more likely to fester and they're more likely to get crazy
about it and obsess about it.
Like I retweeted this one dude the other day about something and I saw him going
back and forth with people for 13 hours.
Yeah.
That's not retweeted him.
And he just was battling people all day.
It became his life.
I mean,
it was every minute for 13 hours.
This guy was going back with people.
There's pro folks like that out there and you have to realize that you can get
caught into their web of psychosis.
Uh,
sorry.
That's good.
See something off topic.
No,
go ahead.
You want to talk about anxiety?
Sure.
Do you,
do,
you know this is,
we're getting into this.
This is beautiful man.
I think it is.
I like how raw this discussion is.
Do you know the surge,
the full body surge of anxiety?
I felt when you were like,
let's stop there.
This is getting way too personal.
This is really dude.
Oh my God.
It felt like I stuck my finger in a light socket.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
No,
no,
don't be sorry.
I just beating on the same path over and over again.
And it was getting to be like,
you know,
he fucking didn't call me.
You know,
I didn't mean it like that.
I was,
I was saying when you were saying,
why didn't you have a discussion?
I was saying I tried to and that was my attempt to,
and I didn't get a response or I don't know what else to do.
Um,
but then I knew you took it the other way cause what you said and then I went
right back to the beginning.
Don't fuck this up.
First Time and Rogan's podcast,
Brogan doesn't like you.
You went down this hall.
I like you felt like I put my finger in an electric socket.
Well get it out of there.
Go get a bandaid.
The I,
I just,
I've just be at a hundred percent honest.
No,
I know what you're saying.
You know,
it's a complex subject.
It's tricky also too.
I want to,
you know,
I'm not,
I'll talk about myself as openly as I'll talk about anybody else.
Like,
you know,
beat my ass.
I'll beat on myself.
Yeah,
it's a luck,
man.
You people fuck up and they say things that are wrong.
They say things they don't mean.
The real question is,
did he say things that he doesn't mean?
Did he say thing?
Was he upset or is that what he really feels?
And if that's the case,
then it becomes a real issue because if that's the case,
if he denies that there's some complexities to it.
But she,
my,
my interactions with him,
my communication with him has not been that my community communications with
him,
this has been,
there is a real problem in those communities,
but it's not his fault.
And He's,
what he deals with is the PC denial of these real problems.
I community,
I agree with that.
And that was always how it seemed to be,
at least at the times when I was in the studio and stuff and would hear it.
And when we hung out,
I mean,
dude,
this is a dude,
I can't stress this enough.
I'm bummed about the whole thing first and foremost because this is a dude I
used to have a great fucking time with.
We would drink did I had so much fun with them and it never got heavy ever,
ever,
ever.
So like,
uh,
the,
when I,
when,
when the discussions of this stuff would come up on the show,
when it w when you're in the room,
it sounded a little more to me like,
like what you're saying,
I'm like,
he's addressing that there was this problem,
but then there was also the times where he would get real mad on the air.
And even in those times you were like,
okay,
he just got a little hot today and that's not that big of a deal.
But then when all these things happened after the show and we're after he was
fired from the shell,
that's when it started to feel kind of like weird to me,
where I was like,
okay,
well was all that anger coming from a different place,
you know,
or,
yeah.
I don't know,
man.
The radio show thing fucked me up.
The white nationalist thing.
Fuck me up.
Yeah.
Well that'll do it.
I mean,
I don't know what,
you know,
I don't know how to take that.
Yeah.
That I know.
Hiding someone's house on fire.
I mean,
that's like you break up with someone,
you fucking burn all their records.
It's so crazy to me that I almost feel like it.
I'm like,
maybe somebody's going to write later tonight and be like,
that's not true.
That was a made up thing.
I don't see he was drinking.
Maybe he was,
who knows?
Who knows?
I don't know.
I would have to communicate with him.
I would have to pay attention to what he actually said on that show.
I didn't see it.
I didn't listen to it.
But the fact that he went on a white national shows not good.
You know,
like he,
isn't it funny,
you know,
this is a funny thing man,
because,
uh,
um,
you know,
going back and forth with people,
because it's something I said the other day on a podcast about Jon Jones where,
uh,
I said that I think that a lot of the hate that Jon Jones gets,
it's possible
that some of it might be because of racism.
I said,
I wonder if some of it might be because of racism.
That was my exact words.
And people were,
you know,
said like there's headlines of things and said white guilt,
Rogan thinks that,
you know,
this is,
it's all because of racism and it's such as a hot button topic.
Right?
You know,
if you bring it up in any form at all,
you bring up racism in any form at all.
People just immediately.
It's just so it's a weird topic.
It's a tough subject,
which is why I think if you're going to address problems in a community,
you have to also address potential solutions.
Uh,
I don't,
and I don't think that happens often in the race discussion.
I think the race discussion is almost always two sides attacking one,
one side on a hard blind attack and another side on a hard blind defense.
But there's like double standards.
And here's one of them.
The heavyweight champion of the world is dude named Cain Velasquez.
Awesome fire,
great guy boxing the heavyweight UFC heavyweight champion.
Um,
and uh,
he has brown pride tattooed across his chest because he's Mexican Brown pride.
Could you imagine if there was a white guy who was the heavy,
if Brock Lesnar won the heavyweight title and then got white pride tattooed
across his chest.
Yeah,
but here's the difference.
Here's to me,
here's the difference.
That argument Brown pride never meant the same thing as white pride.
White pride has always been synonymous with white power,
always that those two terms have never not been linked to one another.
So you put white pride out there,
it sounds like white power.
People start going down that road and they're like,
what the fuck is this guy all about brown pride when it's like,
hey man,
I'm from a suppressed,
people are oppressed people.
Excuse me.
Uh,
and,
and hey man,
I'm,
I'm proud of who I am.
Nobody would have a problem with a white guy.
That's where it's at.
Italian pride or Irish pride,
Russ.
True.
Nobody would have a problem with that.
That's very true.
It's overall white would be an issue.
But that's true.
If someone had Irish pride written under chest,
like of Collin,
uh,
um,
Mcgregor.
Conor McGregor rather had a Irish pride on his back as a famous Irish fighter
and we would give a fuck.
No,
nobody would,
nobody would care at all.
Proud Irishman has done wrong with that.
He says he's a proud Irishman.
Yeah,
I mean it's English pride would be fine.
And I'll anyone Polish German navy,
not chairman German would be a real issue and be like,
what are you proud about?
Exactly?
Engineering our cars.
Okay.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
I mean a company accomplishments assigned.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
I mean,
this whole,
why do it?
It goes back to the thing you said about certain communities having to deal
with,
uh,
certain setbacks,
right.
I'm not putting words in your mouth here.
That's essentially what you said.
Certain communities have had certain setbacks.
The white community as a whole has not faced too many setbacks.
It's just a fact.
Most of global tyranny,
uh,
violence,
genocide,
whatever has a big chunk of it has been perpetuated by white people.
And white people have pretty much prevailed in the majority in,
in most of the societies that they have ever existed.
In not saying there aren't poor white people.
I don't agree with that whole white people problems.
Bullshit.
You know,
I'm not saying that white people can't have a hard time.
Ah,
and I'm not saying that there aren't people that aren't white that are as well
off or way better off than a lot of white people.
Right.
But if you want to speak in generalities,
a of race white has had the least amount of headaches.
So it's tough when the people that have had the least amount of setbacks in the
least amount of headaches stand to the side and go,
stop your complaining.
Stop your complaining.
Because then it starts to be like,
fuck you man.
Fuck you.
That's like somebody going,
you know Joe,
you know man,
you,
oh
did you take Jujitsu when you were a kid?
Cause your upbringing was so bad.
Oh,
stop fucking war.
You know what I mean?
Then you want to be like,
hey fuck you.
You don't know anything about my fucking upbringing.
I probably wouldn't handle it that way,
but go ahead.
But I'm saying it would feel disrespectful if I spoke to you.
I don't think the comparison is like a martial arts comparison because yeah,
I think the race issue is a bigger issue.
Of course it's bigger,
it's darker,
it's more fucked up.
And racism to me is one of the,
it's one of the most unfortunate aspects of humanity.
This idea of just seeing someone,
basing it on all the data that you've accumulated in the x amount of years
you've been alive,
all the bad experiences you've had with,
uh,
white people or black people,
whatever it is that you have a racism towards,
and then automatically assuming that this person who you have no interaction
with whatsoever is negative based on that.
It's just so limiting and it's so unfortunate.
It's one of the most unfortunate aspects of being a person.
So I can never support it.
But,
um,
I think it's a complex subject for debate.
It's a very complex subject.
There's a lot going on there and anybody that pretends it isn't,
whether it's Anthony or whether it's on the progressive side,
you know,
who,
whichever side has an a non nuanced opinion on it.
I think yes,
the service to a complex topic.
I have a,
I have a real problem when the topic is addressed,
uh,
with,
with the,
um,
the approach of stop your belly aching.
Yeah,
let's just,
the people fucking with you.
You know,
it's this simple.
Do you know what I mean?
It's this simple
guys,
get up slavery,
get over it.
I mean,
I've heard people say that,
I've heard people say slavery,
get over it.
I've heard Jewish people say,
oh,
I'm sick of hearing this.
We were in the Holocaust and it's like,
you guys were,
and that's fucking terrible.
But at the same time,
guys,
Jesus,
I'm not saying all Jewish people say that,
but like I've heard Jewish people say that about black.
I've heard black people say,
we don't give a fuck up to the house.
It's not just white people.
It was my point.
Or,
you know,
or,
or the classic stereotypical white people doing this,
it comes from all sides.
You know,
Italian people and Irish people will say,
oh,
big deal.
We were in the ghettos when we first came here.
It's like,
yeah,
but it's just everybody's got their different,
they're different run through this and there's a snowball effect that happens
and it's,
it's
complicated.
Yeah,
no,
it's definitely complicated,
you know?
Yeah.
So I mean,
um,
it,
it would be nice if we could just judge people and who sucks and then figure out
why they suck and then,
but you know what,
man,
I wonder if it's even fucking possible to ever work it out.
I kind of feel like to the day humans stop until the day we become something
else.
I just don't see how there's ever going to be a universal group of people that
gets it.
Right.
Like,
like where anybody,
any culture ever,
like completely gets it right with his no fuck heads.
There's no jealousy.
There's no bullshit.
There's no insecurity or nonsense or I think other countries on the planet have
a shot at it.
Really.
I don't think this one has got a shot at Iceland or something like that where
there's only a hundred people.
Yeah.
I mean Canada might have a shot,
you know,
like they do better than us.
I'll tell you that.
I think other countries might have a shot at complete harmony amongst people of
any color,
whatever.
It will never happen here.
This country is built on a disgusting foundation.
There are too many skeletons in the closet.
There's too much dirt,
too much pain.
It's built on.
It's just build on too much pain and turmoil and and deceit and,
and whatever.
And it's like when you start something like that,
when you start the practice like that,
steal the land,
steal the people so we can prosper it.
How could it ever bounce back?
Because that just will continue and continue and continue and snowball and
snowball and stumble until you have these seemingly unfixable problems,
seemingly unfixable.
And I don't say that to a t to,
to take hope away from anybody that's in a dire situation.
I think all these things are able to be Rah,
Rah risen above on an individual level,
but individual level,
an individual levels.
But I mean,
for God's sakes,
it's like we have,
you look at the situations in the inner cities because of all these different
factors that we're talking about,
uh,
and how it,
and
how it got to where it is now and everything.
It's like,
how could you ever in a million years rectify that?
All right,
let me tell you this.
What if you're,
you're the president,
President Derosa all of a sudden they say,
we've decided to,
you know,
start electing standup comedians.
They,
they,
they have good philosophical points.
Like,
what would you do?
What would you do to try to fix shit?
Do you have any answers or are you just look at it and go,
it's all fucked up.
Do you ever let go pass?
It's all fucked up.
Do you ever like,
see if I was going to do something about it,
what would I do?
I have a very hard time seeing past I,
yeah,
this is,
this would be my one suggestion.
Uh,
it would be
strive for independence,
strive for individual success,
strive for individual success.
Because when you try everybody,
everybody,
I think by just by default,
I don't know what it is.
I guess it's just survival tactics or whatever.
We all sort of have that run with the pack mentality.
You know?
It's like when you're growing up,
no matter what kind of neighborhood you live in,
whether it's a suburb or the projects,
or in a fucking country,
dirt road on a country to where,
excuse me,
there's always the one kid that's maybe going places and that one kid always
gets the same advice you want to go anywhere.
I'm going to stop hanging around with these fucking knuckleheads that you're
running around with because these guys are going to hold you back.
Why?
Because for some reason in anybody's community,
everybody,
the mentality,
the notion is stick together.
If you leave your,
that means you think you're better.
That means you think you're different.
We don't want it.
Dude,
it happened to me and I'm from the fucking suburbs.
So it's not just a,
it's not just a thing you hear about in rap songs when guys are talking about
people in the projects holding,
trying to hold them back.
It's a thing that happens all over.
So if I was the president,
I were the president,
I would say to people,
strive for independent success.
Stop worrying about what's happening to the people.
I'm not saying like in a callous went fuck the people around you,
be concerned about your community,
but strive for independence success because you're not going to be able to fix
the problem from within.
You have to get out and fix it from the outside.
And if enough people can get out and start to assist from the outside,
then there's a chance there's a chance of fixing this.
There's a chance he's
break up the neighborhood.
That's what I heard say,
just fucking the roast is trying to break up the neighborhood.
I was laughing what Ron on from Ron and Fez about it,
like,
like Philly and he's like,
you know,
like we were just laughing about like when trying to get out of Philly and like
the suburbs around Philly and stuff and like guys just being like,
where are you?
We go in,
we got,
we got these sandwiches,
you know what I mean?
And it's like we were laughing cause it's just like,
yeah,
yeah.
I like,
I would have people be so fucking passive aggressive with
me and,
and you know,
like it took years and then like when I started to find
a little bit of success in the business,
people that I was friends with would say things to me like,
fuck you dude.
Oh mister fucking comedians back in town.
And it's like,
this is just shit.
People do wherever you live.
They don't always do that though,
is there's a lot of people that don't do that.
But I know this isn't,
you know,
there's a little bit of that crabs in a bucket.
Shit going on the east coast.
Yes.
East Coast.
More so I think,
and I,
we've talked about this before,
but I believe it's because they are the children of immigrants that like almost
everyone on the east coast is live.
The grandfathers or the great grandfathers came over from Europe or some other
country landed on the east coast and stayed there.
Whereas by the time people got to the west coast,
there are a bit more progressive people,
more wanderlust,
more people like looking for different options.
See,
I don't totally agree.
Well I think it happens here in a very different way.
How's it happen here?
Uh,
I think here there's a,
there there's a massive,
um,
I'd say almost bleeding heart liberal mentality and
at least from what I've,
from what I've experienced here,
um,
as being somebody who needs to sort of assimilate into this system that's here,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not to a point in my life where I can kind of just go off and do my own
thing and,
and be okay.
Like I still need to like meet the right people and,
and kind of work my way into the system and all that stuff.
And familiarize myself with them.
And I find that there is a very,
very,
like I said,
almost bleeding heart mentality here and it feels,
it feels like the same thing to me except in the other direction where it's
like,
don't go against the pack.
Don't say that.
Don't you dare say that because let me just clarify.
You're talking about show business?
Well,
in my la experience,
but I,
I think the city itself,
I think the cow,
at least southern California,
I think there's a certain common mentality that exists here.
Like,
Hey,
you can't act that way.
That's to Ed.
Edgy meaning on edge.
Not meaning you're saying as he thinks.
Well you,
but you're the majority of the people that you're communicating with a show
business people though,
right?
Uh,
probably a problem with the show business that you're communicating with your
talking about like people and television and things along those lines is that
there's a lot of people trying to get people to hire them for things,
trying to get people to cast them in shows,
trying to get people to give them deals,
trying to get people to like them.
And the way to get people to like them as to subscribe to whatever popular
opinions these people subscribed to.
And in show business,
it's almost universally liberal.
And that's one of the things that people like Charlton Heston or John void or
Clint Eastwood have always complained about the price of the rare Hollywood
conservatives because everyone in Hollywood is liberal.
And I think that that's,
there's some valid discussion to that.
But I think it's also the nature of the beast itself where you want people to,
like,
you want people to accept you and there's a lot of fake fucks out here because
of that.
Because the business itself,
it,
it sort of rewards fakery,
it rewards conformity and the conformity,
a lot of it is this sort of left wing liberal thinking.
So,
and when I'm,
when I'm saying is,
and I agree with you,
that's how they get work.
And I agree with you.
Uh,
what I'm saying is though,
I think that mentality exists everywhere.
It can sure that I want people to like me.
You're,
it's,
it's survival.
It's survival.
It's,
yeah.
You know,
I think it was like there's a car in one line where he says species first in
first interest is always survival.
Uh,
so like,
you know,
I think,
I just think that's a thing every day.
It's,
it's,
it's why whenever any one of us has at a party and we're outnumbered in opinion,
whether it's a political discussion or we're fucking discussion about people
think Katy Perry's the best,
whatever,
that's when you just have to just walk away.
Well,
not sure,
but the best what Scott?
Great till we're done basically donut,
but you won't walk away.
Sure.
But I'm saying like most of us feel that,
that you tense up and you go,
I don't want to say I don't really like Katy Perry's tits because now everybody
in the room's going to be like,
what the fuck are you talking about,
dude?
Do you see what I'm saying?
Like I just,
I,
I don't know.
I might be putting too fine a point on it.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I know you're saying
though,
I know he's saying this is definitely a strong urge to conform as part of being
a human being and yeah,
you're right.
It's part of like the only way you can ensure your survival is that you're a
part of a group.
I mean,
that's,
that's ingrained in our DNA because at one point in time,
that's how we survived.
When marauding tribes would come into our villages,
you had to stay United as a United front.
And I think there's,
it's a stronger urge in these places where,
you know,
like in Philly,
in places along those lines where,
you know,
these communities stay in tact.
Whereas in La there's more wandering la,
everyone's transient.
They came here from another place,
they move around and I don't think it's the same thing,
but there's definitely like Brian posted that thing up.
I don't know if you saw it,
but they did a Twitter map of hate speech east coast to west coast and racial
and homophobic.
I look at it and look at it.
It's overwhelmingly east coast welcomingly and I personally,
it was just my own theory.
It's probably like Michael Jackson doesn't have any balls theory.
It's probably socks.
But I think that a lot of that has to do with the spread of immigration.
And that my own experience with immigrants,
my grandparents were immigrants on both sides.
And I grew up in,
you know,
New Jersey and then in Boston and I grew up around a lot of immigrants.
People that you know,
were children of immigrants or grandchildren of immigrants.
And I think that that's a lot of what happens.
I think there's just a,
there's a trap,
you know,
and it's not as bad as a trapped,
it's in the impoverished black communities,
but it's still a very similar trap as far as the behavioral trap.
Sure.
People are fucking strange man,
because it took a law of work to get to 2014 with all the rhinos and lions and
fucking poisonous bugs and all the shit that's out there that could fuck you up.
Sure.
It took a long time and a lot of work for us to get to where we are today with
lava lamps and laptops and shit.
You know,
we had,
uh,
we had to get our way through a lot of things and we had to stay protected while
we innovate.
You know,
here's a crazy thing I just totally off subject,
but I think we've beaten this to death anyway.
Um,
they found a huge underground reservoir recently that holds three times as much
water as the earth's oceans.
Yeah.
It's,
well this is on,
it's on fucking Nova.
Okay.
This is a PBS website that has this,
this is,
it's unbelievable.
It's is an unbelievable discovery.
It's a study that was published in science magazine that Earth's water may have
been there all along,
oozing out gradually from the rock deep in the crust.
It was pressed up by intense heat and pressure below the surface because a lot
of our theories about how earth became so covered in water was that,
uh,
was,
was comics was comments that comments,
when you see a comet streaking across the sky,
where you're seeing is melting ice,
you're seeing enormous,
you know,
miles wide chunks of ice that are flying through space.
And the trail,
the tail of the comet is,
is actually ice.
Um,
being,
you know,
evaporating with as these things fly through the air.
So this is,
um,
this new study,
that they,
uh,
have found this water in these subterranean,
um,
uh,
I got,
I don't know how it,
I don't understand it.
There's,
it's,
it's called subterranean would,
would dite,
Ringwood,
EIT,
I dunno what that means.
A deep blue mineral,
chemically similar to a paradox.
P.
E R.
I.
D.
O.
T,
a green middle,
often used in jewelry and that it's,
it's been found in media rights and there's Ringwood.
I'd came from the transition zone between the upper and lower mantle,
about 400 million mile 400 miles below the earth's surface.
It's about 15% of the weight of this stuff turned out to be water.
And,
uh,
if a lot of this,
it says if a lot of this water heavy mineral existed,
underground scientist reasons there might be enough water to explain where
earth's oceans came from.
And so then they started doing these studies and try to figure this out and they
found this insane amount of water below the earth's surface.
Okay.
It's this,
it's this incredible.
What are they,
what are they going to do with the water?
I don't know.
I Dunno.
The layer holds three times as much water as all of the earth's oceans combined.
It's incredible.
So it reduced the,
um,
the,
this right now people think that the earth is 96% water.
All the or the 96% of the water is in the ocean.
Now they're saying it's only 24% of the water on earth is in the ocean.
Really?
Yeah.
I wonder if there's any life in that water.
I don't think so because I think what this saying by this,
they're saying this ring would EIT stuff.
It's that water is compressed in this minerals and these minerals,
see it's,
this is the exact way they word it.
Obviously I'm an idiot,
but bear with me.
Northwestern University professor who led the study found water in subterranean
Ringwood,
EIT,
a deep blue mineral,
chemically similar to paradox,
a green mineral.
Often used in jewelry until a sample turned up in 2008 in a diamond,
coughed up from a volcano Ringwood.
I had only been found in media rights.
The ring would,
I came from the transition zone,
blah,
blah.
If a lot of this water,
every mineral existed underground.
So this water heavy mineral is what contains all this water.
So I don't know if they can get it out of the water.
See,
it sounds like,
you know,
you would,
you would hear that and you would say,
oh,
there's like rivers under the ocean.
I don't think they're saying that.
I think what they're saying is this water heavy mineral is so dense in the earth
under the earth's mantle that doubled the amount of water in it is much more
than the amount that's in the oceans.
Really?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
What I learned.
You know,
Dave,
they're learning shit about the earth.
Just the earth,
the thing we live on,
they're learning things every day.
It's,
there's all,
the data's not in yet.
It's,
uh,
it's,
I find it incredibly overwhelming.
Like,
you know,
we just had that really long discussion about race and how complicated and how
deep that all is.
And that's just a discussion pertaining to people in just this country,
not even the people of the entire world.
And now we're into a discussion about how we're learning about the actual earth
and now there's three times more water here than we thought there.
Well,
whatever it is,
and it's so fucking over like that discussion into that news piece,
it's,
I literally have the same feeling I had when I was at the Grand Canyon and I was
like,
I don't even exist.
This is like,
you know what I mean?
Like I've never felt more like a speck of dust right now.
There I'm completely overwhelmed.
I really mean that.
Well then they can keep finding these goldilocks planets,
these planets in the goldilocks zone that are,
they're capable of supporting the same type of life that exists on earth.
I mean,
scientists say that life can exist in a bunch of different ways and it never,
they never thought before like they're finding life and these volcanic vents
deep,
deep in the ocean where they never thought that any being could survive the
extreme temperatures.
You know,
they're,
they're essentially living off lava and the,
and the ocean floor and these events are giving birth to these weird kind of a
life forms.
What are the life forms like down there?
Some fucking creepy things,
some creepy plant life and weird life.
But they found a new type of mushroom that was recent.
It's a recent study,
new mushroom that defies classification.
It's a new type of life and they just found it.
But with the animal,
the lava animal thing.
When you say animal life,
do you mean literally animal life microscopic things that are alive?
Like this deep sea mushroom that they found.
This is a new one that they found.
Um,
this is a off of the BBC science and environment page is a mushroom shaped,
see animal discovered off and Australian coast that has defied classification
and the tree of life.
So this is a new type of life form that they found.
This is fucking crazy shit,
man.
You know,
finding something like this is extremely rare.
It's maybe only happened four times in the last 100 years are saying they don't
know what it is.
They're like,
what the fuck is this stuff?
It's like,
it's not quite a plant that's fucking wild.
Jesus Christ.
That's literally star Trek Shit.
When when there would be plants with like mouths and eyes.
That might be the beginning of something like that.
Well,
you know,
if you think about plants like Venus fly traps and shit like that where they
have carnivorous plants,
at what point is a plant and animal?
I mean when plants start fucking closing in on flies and eating them.
Yeah,
I get it.
It's a plant,
but that's a predator.
It things lays traps and it actually has action.
It moves.
I always wanted one of those.
Those are dope.
Do you have one?
No,
but I should get them now that I bring it up.
I had one.
I had one that died.
I remember what happened.
What'd he do?
What'd he flies?
Flies to feed it.
Hey,
we have to have a shitty house.
Otherwise you'd be in rude.
It's like you wouldn't have a cat and not have cat food.
You know,
if you have a Venus flytrap,
you can't just fucking water it.
You gotta throw some flies in there.
I wonder what you do.
Do you get by dead flat?
You probably buy dead fives to feed it or some kind of like larva to feed it.
He'd have to hope that somebody left a window open otherwise.
But how cool would that be?
I am such a jacket.
I keep looking at the fucking screen and then it,
yeah,
that's why I tell people.
That's why I've been asking you to shut these off.
Right?
Like there's,
sorry.
That's all right.
There's a plant that eats rats.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I'm not kidding.
No,
there's a plant,
I believe it's in the Amazon.
It's a,
it captures rats.
It captures rats.
Yeah,
it eats mice.
Yeah.
Google that.
Brian's rat eating plant.
There's a video on wimp.com don't play the video cause otherwise we'd get
another fucking strike against us on Youtube.
What do you mean it's so bizarre?
Every time we uh,
play videos or things,
just like there's all these weird,
is this supposed to be fair use?
Like when you're discussing something online,
it fits the boundaries of fair use.
The definition of fair use,
but people could still,
Dubuque dispute it or not.
It's fair use.
And then they put a hold on your youtube video and if it goes against you,
you get a certain amount of them,
they can pull your videos.
It's just fucking stupid.
But is stupid.
There is a plant,
it's a carnivorous plant.
It eats frogs and it eats mice,
ate,
eats,
all kinds of different shit.
Really?
Yeah.
If you just Google it,
it's called,
here's a fucking name and a half.
Right?
It's a who is,
that's called?
Yeah,
it's called net pen.
This at 10 baroque.
He,
is it possible that you could put it up on the screen and not put it on the
screen where the people at home see it?
Can you do that?
Meaning we watch it,
but they can see it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This just,
if you want to Google it folks,
just Google a plant that eats rash.
I did fucking incredible.
I swear to God.
I thought you were yelling at him for a second and I got super uncomfortable.
What do you mean versus now?
Would you ever do you went,
is it possible for you?
And I thought you were going to be like,
is it possible for you not to fucking keep turning,
switching the script.
I thought that's what you were going to do.
And I was like,
oh Jesus,
I don't want to see this happen full with anxiety.
Do they?
Dude,
I am.
You know,
you get a lot of massages.
I get massages every day.
She'd smokes weed every day.
I smoke weed every day.
Uh,
I don't know,
Dude.
If I look at this ratty and plant man,
no,
the folks at home can see this.
What are they seeing?
Just us.
Your logo.
Okay,
good.
So this is the fucking plant.
I guess it's growing here.
Is that what's going on here?
Yeah,
this is it growing up.
So it gets to a certain size and when it gets to a certain size,
um,
it's,
it's completely kind of diverse.
It eats frogs,
mice.
It captures them.
It opens up like this,
this thing I believe it has like a,
a sweet fermented,
a smell to it and these things go in it because they think this is like some
food in there and go in a Jackson.
Is that a snake or is that no,
that's,
that's it's like 10 to Kohl's or whatever the fuck it is.
Jesus Christ.
This is literally like little shop of horrors.
Shit.
Yeah,
it is.
It's like invasion of the body snatchers type shit.
That thing is fucking nasty.
Look,
it's enormous too.
That's the weird thing about it.
It's,
it's an enormous,
enormous thing that literally looks like a star Trek plant.
[inaudible] yeah,
you would think that would be like from avatar or something like that.
Right.
But it is a real thing.
Thank you for having a more recent reference than star Trek.
Keep.
That's my,
that was the best Scifi.
I'm terrible sometimes with references.
I want to do now.
Is it going to show a rat go into it?
Yeah.
Would eventually show,
uh,
something go into it.
I forget what I've,
I've seen this video,
but there's a bunch of videos of them online.
Um,
these are,
uh,
they're fairly recent discoveries to,
I don't think they discovered it.
Tilted the two thousands.
Yeah.
Here it is.
May,
2010,
the International Institute for Species Exploration at Arizona State University
selected this plant is one of the top 10 new species described in 2009.
So in 2009,
they started a finding that this thing,
a real plant.
I don't understand how we didn't know about a plant until 2009.
Oh,
there's a lot of plants we still don't know about in the Amazon.
That's incredible to me.
Well,
the Amazon is so fucking big.
You know,
when you,
if there was a weird distortion thing,
when you look at,
um,
any sort of a,
a map,
you know,
like,
have you ever seen like a realistic interpretation of the size of continents?
Uh,
no.
Yeah.
See if we could find that.
Brian realistic.
I'm learning a lot today.
Yeah.
Realistic size of continents.
Do you just read the shit like constantly?
Yeah,
I got problems,
man.
No,
I don't,
I'm not criticizing.
I do,
I have problems.
Um,
not a problem.
Uh,
I'm envious of your knowledge of all this stuff.
I really wished that I had a,
I don't know anything about sports.
I know nothing about sports.
I asked you before if that guy was the boxing champion that you mentioned.
Oh,
Cain.
Valasquez yeah.
I didn't even know that.
Uh,
the,
uh,
I wish I knew.
I find this stuff so interesting and yet I never remember to read any of it.
And then I start to try to look it up and I can't remember your look.
Look how fluffy and big Africa is.
You can fit a whole United States in there and a China and in India,
Andy Italy,
like everything in Africa.
But,
but how the maps were drawn for reasons,
it
just appears smaller.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
It's crazy.
And that's just,
that's the,
the rain forest in the Congo and the African rain forest,
but there's also the South American rain forests.
They're massive.
The rain forest in Brazil and Peru and down there,
I mean there's so many plants and that's one of the reasons why these
pharmaceutical companies keep going down there to try to explore and find out
new plants that can provide,
you know,
new drugs and good reasons for cancer medications and cure diseases and things
along those lines.
And also there's some of them that they,
uh,
they're,
they're using for like,
they're trying to do research on this aunt as an aunt called the bullet ant,
one of the most painful stings in the world.
But it,
uh,
it doesn't just sting you.
Um,
oh,
not the bullet ant.
Catch your ass.
That's,
it really fucks you up.
That one fucks you up.
They're using that.
They're trying to use that for something else.
I got to confused.
It's actually the Brazilian wandering spider.
I was going to bring up the Brazilian wandering spiders.
So it's so fucked up.
It stings you.
It's in the jungle,
Brazil.
It stings you and gives you an unbelievably painful erection to the point where
if you survive where a lot of people don't,
if you survive,
your Dick is broken forever.
It'll never work it again in red lines your Dick
and it works in the same sort of way like Viagra works where it,
it,
it gives you nitric oxide,
it produces some massive amount of nitric oxide,
your body.
So all of your muscles become incredibly painful.
Like just,
just massive agony.
Like think of like your whole body just,
just red lined all the time and your Dick,
your dicks,
hard as fuck.
And it breaks.
It breaks your Dick
so you don't orgasm like no during this scan
me.
Maybe if you stuck your finger up your ass while I was going down,
he
might be able to pull something off.
It's not make,
it wouldn't be happy.
Wouldn't be happy coming.
There'll be the last one.
Yeah,
the uh,
that's fucked up.
What's that thing called?
It's called the Brazilian wandering spider.
And so these pharmaceutical companies are trying to figure out how to make that
the new like supervised Agora had to take.
Not that they need it,
like doesn't Viagara work,
can't they just move on?
And the reason is just like they want to have something that's new,
you know,
it's like there's competing forces like there's Viagara than their Cialis came
along.
We last longer and then you know,
there's other ones that we don't give you as much of a headache and then there's
this one and that one and they're always trying to find some new one,
but they're trying to figure out a way to use this evil fucking murderer,
spiders,
venom and get your Dick hard with it.
It's like that old,
it's like that old leary joke about cocaine or crack and he's like,
oh wait,
this is the only country where cocaine wouldn't be fast enough.
Somebody needed something faster.
But that's how it is with those,
with those penis drugs,
it's like how much fucking stronger and faster does this need to get?
How much harder does that your Dick need to be?
It's an unnatural.
Yeah.
Erection.
I don't mean just because it's caused a naturally,
I mean,
the type of erection you get from it is fucking a natural.
Great.
You know when it's also,
have you found that like you've saved,
they found that they've isolated components in plants that can give you that.
What else is out there?
Is there something out there that makes kids grow taller?
Is there something out there that cures autism?
Is there something out there that makes your hair grow back?
Because there's something out there that,
you know,
there's,
there's so many hundreds of thousands of plants that are undiscovered.
I mean,
there's just areas where they just don't go.
There's people don't get to,
the density of the rain forest is just so incredible.
I'm,
I'm absolutely amazed that this spider,
the wandering spider can do this to you and scientists are forget like that.
It's even stronger than Viagra.
But like that,
scientists are like,
let's fuck with that.
Let's see what we can get out of it.
You know what I mean?
Like it's just,
no,
leave that thing alone.
It's the worst thing in the world.
Leave it alone.
Don't try to,
unless you're going to try to make some kind of bio weapon with it.
You know what I mean?
Like leave it the fuck alone.
That's one of the worst.
Um,
apparently one of the worst things you can ever get.
One of the most toxic venoms that a,
they've ever discovered.
A lot of people die from it too.
It sounds horrible,
but a terrible world.
That's one of the things I don't like about the west coast is like there's a
much higher concentration of like poisonous spiders and shit out here.
That was never a thing on the east coast,
but I felt like I had a black widow in my house one day and it was just like,
what the fuck?
Twice now in my house I've killed spiders that have like clear spots on their
tail or not tail,
but you know what I mean?
The buck part,
whatever that's called.
What's that?
One of them was a fucking black widow.
It had a big fucking dot on its back red big red thing.
And it was red or white.
I can't remember which black widow,
which the black widow is.
But whatever it is,
it was that.
Yeah,
they fuck with,
I mean they don't fuck with you.
You have to like get near them and scare them for them to sting you,
but their goddamn everywhere out here.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
Black widows are all over the place.
My back porch is literally,
you can find 20 of them and just sitting down there everywhere there's,
I have so much trees and spiderwebs and what sucks is that night I'll go out and
have a cigarette and I've walked through so many spider webs that I'm surprised
that I,
do you ever get bit by one?
I probably I had on,
I have to have isn't a black widow like very poisonous.
I think the brown widow is,
I don't know.
I know one of them is more poisonous than the other.
I met my ex girlfriend's dog actually died from getting bitten by one of the
weaknesses question,
well we don't have to go to the bathroom on this show.
We'll talk about phones while you're gone.
As you're talking about the hardest Dick of all time.
I have like I'm special gender almost straight jack off for now.
Yeah.
I got to think he has look at them.
I'm just excited.
Going to Jack off to alleviate anxiety.
Did you uh,
check out the new iPhones and the new watch and all that stuff?
Yeah,
they look pretty cool.
Did you hear about them?
The macworld staff got,
almost all of them got laid off today.
They,
they work,
they had to work like crazy covering the launch of the new phones and then
today,
like everybody got laid off the biggest apple news day of the year and they laid
off like almost the entire staff.
Well it's so,
I mean that's,
that's ridiculous.
But it's amazing that they even lasted this long,
right?
I mean cause it's a magazine.
Yeah.
I mean magazines are so pointless.
Today's Francis.
Yeah.
By the time you buy a Mac world right now,
it's not talking about the new iPhone.
It's not talking about all the news in the last month.
Even probably it's
okay,
it's going away.
What they're saying is macworld Dotcom will still continue,
but macworld print has gone to wow economic reality of running a print
publication.
You know what they should do?
Bring back silent movies.
Heard they're not going to come back.
Do you guys know how to make smoke signals?
Sell smokes.
Yeah,
they're going away.
Why is everybody sad?
It sucks that those folks lost their jobs,
but they should just translate.
What they should have done is just transitioned those writers into the Mac
world.com thing.
They should have worked on it.
If there were valuable employees and you know,
everybody's pissed off.
A lot of people were pissed off because they made these people work really hard
and go crazy too.
Um,
you know,
to,
to launch this new product and to cover the launch and that,
uh,
you know,
these people at this grueling day of Marathon,
iPhone coverage and then they fired him
there also were geeky in the fuck out of there.
I do.
We're at the apple event.
This is so cool.
Let's take pictures and call it a job.
Yeah,
there's always going to be a little of that,
right?
It's going to be a little,
uh,
what I find interesting is the new,
payment plans that,
that they're introducing with this new iPhone where you're pretty much not going
to have a credit card anymore.
You're not going to have your bank cards anymore.
You're just waving your phones and it's,
it's sending out a unique number to the cash register.
It's almost like how bitcoins are where it's,
it's,
it's interesting,
but it does it have to work where,
um,
the people at the cash register have to have a device to pick it up?
Is that what it is?
But when you have that already
for androids four.
Okay.
No,
I don't know.
But,
but before the launch,
they,
uh,
apple is working with all the biggest like credit card companies like,
you know,
chase and capital one and all that.
So a lot of big stores already have it.
Um,
I know like there is versions of it that's existed already.
Like,
and I pay at Starbucks,
I use my phone,
you know,
but it's,
this is inside the phone.
I think it's called near frequency NFS or something like that where it sends out
a signal.
It's actually,
yeah,
like a little local radio based.
I wonder like if it has a limit,
could you buy a car like that?
Did you go to a Ford dealership and pick up a month?
Your credit card?
You're a Amex,
American express black or whatever you have,
you know,
have,
wow.
You would have it on your phone.
That would be dope as fuck to buy a car with your phone.
Yeah.
I don't even know why I want to buy a car with my phone,
but I want to buy a car with my phone.
But it seems so ridiculous.
So there are 4.7 inches and 5.5 inches is the new iPhones.
It's graduations.
You finally caught up fucking idiots here.
Should have done that a million years ago.
Jesus Christ there.
They're fucking iPads.
They've advanced the sync technology,
which is nice with that.
Like pass it off feature.
Put that back up to the front.
Yeah.
I'm going to try to find a better,
uh,
the,
this is the 4.7 inch.
This is what?
Four inches?
The five inches,
four inches.
And I have a Samsung Galaxy s five,
which is only a,
it's five inches.
That's 5.5.
I believe.
That's fucking giant.
That's as big as what I had.
I used to have the note,
which was like five,
seven I think.
Yeah,
somewhere on then I think the galaxies five,
five or five.
Three.
It's bigger than the new iPhone.
I did a comparison.
The galaxies bigger the note or the galaxy s five.
Well,
the galaxy is bigger than the regular iPhone six.
The iPhone six extra large or whatever the fuck it's called.
Deluxe I think is either the same size as the galaxy are a little bigger.
Put that up again so I get to it.
Yeah.
I'm trying to find a better ones,
but I did a side by side with the regular new iPhone six in the galaxy s five.
Well,
the good thing about the big one,
he said it's supposed to have two hours more battery life.
Yeah.
That battery's way better for some reason on other fuckers,
they always catch up with the big ones.
But you know they've been saying this for every fucking iPhone that comes out.
They go the batteries better now and it's no it's not.
It's never been better once it is better,
the issue is that you have more need for juice because you have four g LTE and
three g and Wifi and all that stuff.
Things are more intensive.
Like programs,
games,
they just use more juice.
So the batteries are better,
but it depends on what you're using them for.
But they never break it down like that.
They always go like this new one.
They go this new battery,
11 hours of video watching time.
It's like,
yeah,
no that's what you said the last two phones and it's never that.
Yeah.
And then when you complain they go,
well see cause you're your Bluetooth fuck you follow apple.
There's a lot of reasons.
One of the biggest reasons is if you don't have good service in your house and
it's always searching for signals and stuff like that.
Wifi and all that stuff is the thing that drains you out because you will have
your Wifi on your phone and then you'll go to Chili's.
And so the whole time it's like trying to search for Wifi.
You don't even realize it.
It says draining your battery.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing what,
just simple like turning on to airplane mode or does to your,
you know,
or turn off Wifi,
turning off Bluetooth,
turning off,
you know,
turn off four G,
right?
Yeah.
She's three g.
That's dumb.
It's terrible.
If you try to go online with three g now you're so spoiled.
Yeah.
I bring my friend Aubrey has a Tesla.
It's fucking dope.
It's the most ridiculous car.
Those,
those crazy electric cars.
And is this the phone?
Yeah,
he has a crazy electric car and they're not,
we're not sure on that.
Where we get pulled over,
we now know this is just for us.
Yeah.
Um,
his,
uh,
Tesla,
his car has us giant screen man.
This huge screen.
It's like a laptop,
like a bigger than a laptop.
It's like an Imac that's in the middle of the console.
And that's where everything is.
It doesn't have any buttons.
Everything is all touch screen on this thing and you talk to it.
Like he could say,
play Joe Derosa comedy and it'll go to Spotify and it'll go,
why
don't you to come over there and hug you?
Like we were in the car and he said,
uh,
came,
come up with a,
you know,
say anything.
I go arctic monkeys.
So he goes,
play Arctic monkeys.
It goes,
finds it on Spotify,
brings up a list of songs he presses play and starts playing in Arctic monkeys
song,
but it's three g and I was like,
where's the four g bitch?
You ain't got it.
No.
Four g up in his mother fuckers.
And that's no g three G is like slow three G's.
No.
Gee,
here's Lizza.
Here's the,
it's talking about the new camera that's in the,
in the iPhone.
But here's interesting a here they do payment thing.
Check us out.
We're introducing apple pay fast mobile payments.
I don't think this pay thing is a great idea.
I think it's awesome.
And you can pay with your Dick because if you use your thumb finger,
thumb recognition,
you could use your deck for their Dick Recognition and find that unique pattern
on your skin of your cock.
And then he'd get buy things with your cock.
Listen,
it's,
it's not hear me.
No,
I heard Ya.
I've been rubbing my dick on my phone for years
now,
but I don't think it's bad about it.
I remember years ago Burgos uh,
he goes,
they're moving in all the foam though.
They're moving it all the fucking phone.
And then the second the government decides they want to shut you down.
Boom,
you're done.
Cause it's all on the trip and it's happening now.
I used to be like,
you're nuts.
What are you talking about?
And now it's finally happening.
It's like your life is on that fucking phone,
your life.
But you choose to put your life that phone.
I mean,
there's a lot of things on that phone,
but you know,
if you want,
you can do whatever you want,
man.
You don't have to jump along.
You could be that guy that lives up in fucking big bear.
You've got a cabin somewhere and you your chop your own wood and you've got a
water.
Well that you get all your wall.
You could be that guy if you really want it to.
You just have to move towards that.
You gotta jump along dude,
jump along.
You gotta you said you don't have to jump along.
You gotta jump along.
Do you want to watch,
look at the watch?
No,
fucking retake it.
I think it's stupid.
I think it's,
if it catches on like the iPhone did it,
everyone has it.
It's going to make so much more sense because being able to just go like to your
wrist and be like,
get me directions,
you know,
talk to your wrist or,
or there's also does interesting technology and it would,
that's a,
if you have a phone on Joe or if you have a wrist on and you're in my contacts,
I can send you private messages just to your,
you're like,
hey,
check out the chick going through the door right now.
You or send you a like a quick drawing of something.
Only you would have to use it for creeping on people.
It won't be suspicious at all.
As you're staring at your watch and your lips are moving.
I like that other girl works with a winder thing.
Like it doesn't have a touch screen.
The winder thing is how they use it.
That little thing is a handle.
The knob on the side is uh,
it's going to be interesting though because it seems like that's,
you know,
could cause also problems if you hit it and he sings a phone call fucking
working for directions to the moon.
Directions on your wrist that are tiny.
It does.
It just doesn't seem convenient to me.
That seems goofy.
But it's like the,
um,
the heart rate monitor thing is,
it's got different bands.
It's got three different models.
There's actually a gold one,
which is grammar to me,
maybe even over thousands of dollars.
And they have a sport edition,
which is like a rubber,
like more show me the diamond crusted one for rappers.
Is there a diamond crusted one for rappers?
Not yet.
I'm going to get into that business tomorrow.
We call my accountant.
Put all the money and the diamonds and watches.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I just think it's just kind of pointless.
Like I love how they use it.
English got to sell it.
You know why?
Because you can't use a guy from New York check out this goal.
In addition,
tastes have developed to be up to twice as hard.
The standard gold,
the developed to be up to twice as hard as a standard gold.
You can't have it.
Nobody would trust him.
She had a guy from another land,
well maybe they're different in this other land called England.
I want here one of them sell this product.
It sounds much more respectable.
I see that knob breaking a lot.
That's the next broken iPhone is broken.
Nonstop working.
Yeah,
could be.
I mean the one thing about Apolis,
they're pretty good about testing shit pretty rigorously before they release it.
I guess the biggest problem is seven.
But the biggest problem is,
is that the battery they're not happy with because right now it's supposedly,
it's rumored the lasts about a day
and they want it,
you know,
days.
Right?
And when they say a day,
does that mean a day with you using it?
Right.
Or a day with a regular normal person.
It was a job using it.
Yeah.
Now,
and they say a day on the iPhones too,
and it's nowhere fucking near it.
I'm going to make the best point than anybody.
It's impossible has made about this.
Okay.
Right now on this show,
okay,
here's why that's a dumb idea.
The new iPhone has a significantly bigger screen for a fucking reason.
This is a completely tiny,
completely inconvenient screen.
Who the fuck wants that?
Everybody wants a device that's easier to use.
And I don't see how this is this,
just like when they did the Ipod Nano and they tried to put it all on the screen
and it was too fucking small.
Tell you why.
Because this is as easy as it is.
Uh,
you have your phone in your pocket.
You're talking to somebody,
you have a little vibrate on your hand.
You look down just calling me.
Oh No.
You're always a vibrate in your pocket.
No,
no.
Just the vibrant in your hands Kinda.
It's got it has you got to turn out on both.
If you want
what the girl's giving you a hand job and you feel your Dick Vibrate and then
she starts looking at arrest and she wants to stop.
That'll be annoying.
Somebody else's texting are cock block and you mean this is what I'm talking
about.
Nobody thinks ahead.
I'm thinking ahead.
We had a time.
Yeah,
we got five minutes.
Oh,
okay.
Joe Derosa.
This was fun.
It was this about six,
seven hours.
Three hours.
We did three hours.
Was it a full three?
Yeah.
Was I had a great time.
It was fun,
man.
I felt like it was
all different
types of things were happening to them.
I hopefully alleviate any anxiety they might have come up.
That's me,
dude.
That's all me.
That's how you owe x,
escalate it.
Every social interaction for me is Vietnam.
I'm taking this home with me.
This is going to be at all.
And I think don't worry about it.
Do a set tonight.
And you,
are you working when you're in town?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They're there.
Everybody's being very nice to me.
Okay,
cool.
You know,
the,
the death squad guys have welcomed me with open arms,
which I'm very appreciative.
Fourth,
thank you.
Where can people find you this weekend?
Are you in town working tomorrow?
I don't even know.
I'm just doing spots around town this weekend,
but if I'm going to plug something,
I really would like to plug my new album.
Uh,
mistakes were made the besides on iTunes and Amazon,
10 bucks for that available.
It's available now.
The whole length album of rarities from the last seven years.
Oh,
nice.
And then my podcast,
which you can get on my website or on iTunes,
it's called down with Joe to Rossa.
Uh,
I'd love to have more people come and listen.
It's,
I talk about one hour for one topic for an hour,
usually by myself.
Excellent.
And all that stuff.
I'll retweet that right now.
I'm retreating it right now.
And uh,
that,
uh,
the,
the site is a Joe Derosa,
comedy Rose Rosa,
comedy.com.
You can find all this stuff there.
That's also his Twitter,
Joe Derosa comedy.
And uh,
thank brother.
That was fun man.
Thank you very much.
I had a blast.
Thank you so much.
And uh,
thanks to our sponsors,
shit it don't have it in front of me right now.
Hold on.
Blue Apron,
which is a service that they send you ingredients.
You don't have to,
it would just have to say the what's the thing is what they have to where they
have to go.
Okay,
here it is.
A blue apron.com.
Forward Slash Rogan.
Get your first two meals for free.
Go to blue apron.com forward slash Rogen.
Thanks.
Also to dollar shave club.
Go to dollar shave club.com/rogan.
That's dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible]
and uh,
last but not least,
we're brought to you by stamps.com go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone in the upper right hand corner and using the code word j
r e for your $110 bonus offer,
which includes free digital scale and up to $55 a free postage.
And last but not least on at.com o n n,
I t a human optimization website.
Use the Codeword Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
I'll be back tomorrow with timber net from Solo hunters.
And uh,
that's it.
Much love,
big kiss.
He assumed ice house is sold out this weekend.
So you snoozed there's another place you can go Tundra pussies there as well.
Friday night,
see Ya.
Big Kiss.